ओके। सो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ।
ओके चलिए लेट मी नो गाइस। आप सभी एक बार
बता दीजिए। फटाफट बताइए कि इफ आई एम ऑडिबल
एंड विज़िबल क्लियरली। ऑडियो वीडियो
बिल्कुल सही आ रही है सभी को? बिल्कुल
क्लियर क्लेरिटी के साथ सब कुछ बता दीजिए।
फटाफट बताइए फटाफट।
हरी अप गाइस। जल्दी नमस्ते। नमस्ते। गुड
इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल ऑफ यू। नमस्ते।
हां भाई गुड इवनिंग भी है नमस्ते भी है
सभी हैं
वेलकम टू द क्लास 16 ऑफ आवर एसओसी एल1
फ्री लाइव क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग
एंड आई होप आप सभी इस ट्रेनिंग को एंजॉय
कर रहे हैं। एंजॉय भी कर रहे हैं, सीख भी
रहे हैं। एंजॉय करते हुए सीख रहे हैं। ठीक
है? सीखने के साथ-साथ एंजॉयमेंट भी चल रही
है। मजा भी आ रहा है आपको। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके।
या सो सभी लोग आ रहे हैं। वी विल वेट जस्ट
1 मिनट एंड देन वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग।
ओके। ऑडियो वीडियो सब कुछ क्लियर है। ओके
बहुत बढ़िया।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। आई होप आप सभी भी बढ़िया होंगे। अच्छे
होंगे। मजे में होंगे सभी। राइट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए मैं एक बार
यहां पे स्टार्ट कर लेता हूं।
सो आई कैन सी हियर आल्सो।
ओके। सो 21 पीपल आर हियर। सो वी आर वेटिंग
मोर पीपल टू जॉइन द सेशन एंड देन वी विल
बी स्टार्टिंग। सो गाइस आई होप कि आप सभी
को अभी तक के जो सेशंस हैं वो मजेदार लग
रहे होंगे। मजा आ रहा होगा। काफी कुछ सीख
लिया होगा आपने। एंड एसओसी के लिए
नेटवर्किंग का पार्ट अब ओवर होने वाला है।
सो इसके बाद एक नेक्स्ट सेगमेंट हमारा
स्टार्ट होगा एसओसी का एंड देन जो है हम
इसके एक्चुअल जो मेन अ
प्रैक्टिकल पोर्शन है उसके ऊपर आ जाएंगे।
बट उन सारे प्रैक्टिकल पोर्शनंस के लिए ये
जो कंसेप्चुअल एंड थ्योरिटिकल सेशंस आपके
चल रहे हैं ये बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। अगर
आपको इनका आईडिया नहीं है, इसके बारे में
आपको ज्यादा नॉलेज नहीं है, तो वो जो
सेशंस हैं, वो आपके लिए ज्यादा यूज़फुल
नहीं रहने वाले हैं। सीधी सी बात है,
मैंने पहले ही बोला हुआ है। राइट? सो,
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वी आर वेटिंग
मोर पीपल टू जॉइन। लेट्स सी। सभी लोग आ
जाते हैं, तो हम स्टार्ट करेंगे। अभी 27
पीपल आर ओनली देयर एंड वी विल वेट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके 37 नाउ हियर
ओके टिल नाउ टिल देन एवरीवन इज जॉइनिंग
लेट मी
शो यू कि आपके कुछ स्टेप्स जो आपको हर
सेशन से पहले लाइक मैं बताता हूं एंड आपको
करना है यह सारे स्टेप्स फॉलो सबसे पहले
तो आप डेफ़्रॉनिक्स Academy YouTube चैनल
पे जब आ जाएंगे तो लाइव सेक्शन में जाके
यहां पे लाइव वाले जो सेशन है या
प्लेलिस्ट में एसओसी के प्लेलिस्ट में कोई
सी भी एसओसी की वीडियो आप ओपन कर लीजिएगा।
एंड यहां पे आपको दो लिंक्स इसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल जाएंगे। एक WhatsApp
ग्रुप का और एक WhatsApp चैनल का। ग्रुप
स्पेशल एसओसी के लिए हमारा ग्रुप है।
इसमें जितने रिसोर्सेज जो भी डॉक्यूमेंट्स
या नोट्स या लोग जो भी अपकमिंग डिटेल्स
होंगी सर्टिफिकेशन को लेकर या एग्जाम को
लेकर या कुछ भी या इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन को
लेकर सब इसी में आएंगी। तो यह जरूर आपको
जॉइ करना है। इट्स मैंडेटरी। यह हमारा
चैनल है WhatsApp पे चैनल जो डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी नाम से है। एंड यहां पे आपको जॉइ
करना है, फॉलो करना है। ओनली बिकॉज़ कि
आपको सबसे पहले अपडेट मिले। जो भी अपडेट्स
हो हमारी तरफ से ओवरऑल जितनी भी फाइनल
अपडेट्स होती हैं जो भी अपडेट्स होती है
आपको इस चैनल पे मिल जाता है। तो इसको
जरूर से जरूर आपको फॉलो करके रखना है। यह
मेरी Lindin प्रोफाइल है। आप इस पे आके
मुझे फॉलो अप कर सकते हैं। मुझसे कनेक्ट
हो सकते हैं। एंड यहीं पे आप Lindin पे ही
डिफ्रॉनिक्स सर्च करेंगे। तो हमारी कंपनी
का जो Lindin पेज है वो आपको मिल जाएगा।
डिफ़्रॉनिक्सic साइबर सिक्योरिटी के नाम
से। आप इस पेज को आके फॉलो कर सकते हैं।
जहां लगभग 21,000 डिफ्रॉनिक्सर्स हमसे
जुड़े हैं। यहां आपको कंपनी से रिगार्डिंग
जो भी अपडेट्स हैं, जो भी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
है, वो सारी चीजें मिल जाएंगी। साथ ही
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यह Twitter
या एक्स पेज है हमारी कंपनी का। आप इसको
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। यह मेरी Instagram की
पर्सनल प्रोफाइल है। नितेश सिंह हैकर
यूजरनेम के साथ। आप आके यहां मुझसे कनेक्ट
हो सकते हैं। फॉलो कर सकते हैं। यह डिफरिस
एकडमी हमारी कंपनी का Instagram पेज है।
यू कैन गेट हियर टू गेट सम इनेटिव रील एंड
कंटेंट्स ये हमारी वेबसाइट है। ये हमारा
नंबर है। इस पे आप हमें किसी भी तरह से
WhatsApp पे मैसेज करके हमसे कांटेक्ट कर
सकते हैं। कोई भी क्वेरी हो, कुछ क्वेश्चन
हो, आप पूछ सकते हैं। किसी भी तरह का
असिस्टेंस चाहिए यू कैन जस्ट पिंग अस
हियर। दैट्स इट। एंड यहां एकडमी पे जाके
हमारी कोर्सर्सेस को आप एक्सप्लोर कर सकते
हैं। द कोर्सर्सेस बाय डिफ़्रॉनिक्स। ठीक
है? चलिए ये सारी चीजें तो हो गई हैं। एंड
आई होप कि आप इसको फॉलो करेंगे। एंड द
थिंग इज नेक्स्ट कि कोई भी वीडियो जब आप
देखते हैं तो वीडियो के नीचे में आप
देखेंगे हाइप का बटन होता है। आप हाइप के
बटन पे क्लिक करके हाइप कर दिया कीजिएगा
वीडियोस को। जितनी ज्यादा आप हाइप करेंगे
YouTube पे वीडियोस को उतनी ज्यादा
रिकमेंड की जाती है बाय YouTube एंड इट इज़
गुड फॉर लाइक YouTube अ सजेशन एल्गोरििदम
एंड ऑल। तो आजकल चल रहा है ये। तो यू कैन
डू इट राइट? ओके।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
नाउ अ यहां पे आज के सेशन को हम स्टार्ट
करेंगे। आज की जो सेशन है आज जैसा कि
मैंने आपको
टाइटल में दिख गया होगा आपको कि आज हम
बेसिकली नेटवर्किंग का ही एक पार्ट है।
आईपी पैकेट्स एक टॉपिक है एंड थ्री वे
हैंडसेक इसको समझने वाले हैं। ठीक है? एंड
दिस टॉपिक्स आर रियली रियली रियली वेरी
वेरी इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक्स। आपको काफी मजा
आने वाला है ये टॉपिक्स करके। एंड यह
टॉपिक्स काफी ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट होने वाले
हैं क्योंकि एज अ एसओसी क्योंकि आप फर्स्ट
लाइन ऑफ़ डिफेंस हो तो एज अ एसओसी आपका यह
एक तरह से आपका यह फर्ज है आपका
आपकी ये ड्यूटी है कि आप किसी भी तरह के
अटैक को डिफेंड करने के लिए खड़े रहेंगे
एल1 की तरह। एल1 का एक ड्यूटी है यह। ये
आपका ड्यूटी है जो आपको करना ही करना है।
एंड जब भी कोई अटैक होगा किसी नेटवर्क
इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर पे, किसी कंपनी पे, किसी
भी तरह के इंफ्रास्ट्रक्चर पे तो उस टाइम
पे आप पहले ऐसे होंगे डिफेंस लाइन जिनके
ऊपर सारा लोड आता है। और आपको एक-एक चीज
बारीकी से पता होनी चाहिए। एक-एक चीज ना
बहुत माइन्यूटली आपको आईडिया होना चाहिए
कि यह क्या है? अटैक किस तरह का हो सकता
है? किस कैटेगरी में अटैक फॉल करता है?
इसको किस तरीके से आगे लेकर जाना है, कैसे
इसको आगे एग्जीक्यूट करना है, आगे कहां पे
लेकर जाना है, किसको एस्केलेट करना है,
नहीं करना है, एवरीथिंग यू हैव टू हैंडल।
एंड दैट्स व्हाई नेटवर्किंग का बहुत बड़ा
रोल है। नेटवर्किंग के टॉपिक्स का बहुत
बड़ा रोल है। उसी में हम एक टॉपिक आज
पढ़ने वाले हैं आईपी या डेटा पैकेट्स के
बारे में। एंड साथ ही में थ्री वे हैंडशक
एंड टीटीएल के बारे में। सो ये काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक्स हैं। याद रखिएगा। दिस
टॉपिक्स आर आल्सोेंट फॉर साइबर सिक्योरिटी
एथिकल हैकिंग इन एंड इन द एसओसी सेगमेंट
आल्सो देखो आईपी और डेटा पैकेट के ऊपर आने
से पहले मैं आपको सबसे पहले कुछ चीज बताने
वाला हूं ओके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो आईपी पैकेट पे आएंगे उसके पहले लेट मी
शो यू समथिंग देखो इंटरनेट पे
इंटरनेट पे
एक
दो डिवाइस डिवाइसेस के बीच जो कम्युनिकेशन
होती है। ठीक है? जनरली क्या होती है?
मिनिमम टू डिवाइसेस के बीच कम्युनिकेशन
होती है। एक डिवाइस खुद से तो कम्युनिकेट
करेगा नहीं ना। वो तो लूप बैकक पे करेगा,
लोकल पे करेगा। बट जनरली दो डिवाइसेस
चाहिए फॉर द कम्युनिकेशन। उस दो डिवाइस
में एक हमारा क्लाइंट होता है और दूसरा
हमारा सर्वर होता है। सिंपल। ये सबको पता
होगा। राइट? अब देखिए अब इन दोनों
डिवाइसेस में
क्लाइंट जो है वह रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है
एंड सर्वर जो है उसको रिस्पॉन्ड करता है।
ये नॉर्मल सिनेरियो है। हालांकि हम आगे
थ्री वे हैंडशक जब पढ़ेंगे आज के क्लास में
तो देखेंगे यहां तीन स्टेप्स होते हैं। दो
नहीं होते हैं। ये जनरिक एक मैंने केस
बताया जहां पे मैंने आपको दो स्टेप्स
बताए। क्लाइंट रिक्वेस्ट करता है। सर्वर
जो है उसको रिस्पॉन्ड करता है। दैट्स इट।
यहां पे अभी इसी फ्लो के साथ चलते हैं।
थ्री वे हैंडसेक में तीन यहां पर आपको
दिखेंगे। तीन बेसिकली यहां पर रिक्वेस्ट
रिस्पांस का गेम दिखेगा आपको। तो अब यह जो
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है और जो रिस्पांस आ रहा
है इसमें बेसिकली जाता क्या है? होता क्या
है वो? वो होते हैं आईपी पैकेट्स
या डेटा पैकेट्स या इंटरनेट पैकेट्स या
नेटवर्क पैकेट्स कुछ भी बोल सकते हो। तो
बेसिकली वो होते हैं आईपी पैकेट 32 बिट्स
के जो आपको मैंने पहले भी बताया था। 32
बिट्स के एक आईपी पैकेट्स होते हैं। अब ये
आईपी पैकेट्स ही जो होते हैं ना ये
छोटे-छोटे
टुकड़ों में फ्रेगमेंट्स में डिवाइडेड
होते हैं।
एंड जब सर्वर तक पहुंचेंगे क्लाइंट के तो
यहां पे रिअसेंबल हो के एक पूरा पैकेट बन
जाएगा। असेंबल हो जाएंगे। फिर सर्वर से भी
जब जाएगा तो ऐसे ही छोटे-छोटे टुकड़ों
टुकड़ों में ऐसे जाता है ये और फिर जब
क्लाइंट के पास जाएगा तो ये रिअसेंबल हो
जाएंगे। रिअसेंबल हो जाएंगे। अगेन क्या हो
जाएंगे? रिअसेंबल हो जाएंगे। सिंपल। तो ये
जो पूरा का पूरा ये जो छोटे-छोटे पैकेट्स
जो जा रहे हैं इनको हम आईपी पैकेट बोलते
हैं जो कि टाइनीस्ट पार्ट होते हैं
कम्युनिकेशन जो इंफॉर्मेशन जा रही होती
है। सबसे टाइनेस्ट पार्ट इनको हम आईपी
पैकेट या डेटा पैकेट बोलते हैं। ओके गौरव
चलिए काफी लोग आ चुके हैं यहां पे। अच्छी
अच्छी बात है आप लोग देखो अच्छा लगता है
कि
आप लोग कंसिस्टेंसी के साथ आ रहे हैं। कम
से कम 65 पीपल आर हियर अभी। यह कंसिस्टेंट
है फ्रॉम द वेरी बिगिनिंग। एंड मुझे अच्छा
लगता है अगर इसमें से 50 लोग भी
कंसिस्टेंट है तो दैट्स गुड। प्रीटी गुड।
एंड मैंने जैसा कि प्रॉमिस किया था कि आप
अगर अपने साइड से जोश दिखाएंगे, लाइव में
प्रेजेंट रहेंगे तो मेरे साइड से भी आपको
कंसिस्टेंसी दिखेगी। एंड आपको दिख भी रही
होगी कि अभी जो है यह नेक्स्ट क्लास जो
मतलब अभी यह वाली जो क्लास है वो काफी
अर्ली आई है। कुछ ज्यादा गैप भी नहीं हुआ
है। एंड इट हैज़ अराइव्ड। तो सब आपके ऊपर
डिपेंड करता है। टोटली डिपेंड्स ऑन यू।
राइट? चलिए अब यहां पे डेटा पैकेट्स जा
रहे हैं, डेटा पैकेट्स आ रहे हैं। तो कहने
का मतलब यह है कि इंटरनेट पे जो भी आप
ईमेल भेजते हैं, कोई चीज डाउनलोड करते
हैं, कोई मैसेज भेजते हैं, वो सब डेटा
पैकेट या आईपी पैकेट्स ही होते हैं।
इंटरनेट पे जो भी चीजें है, है ना, जो भी
चीजें ट्रैवल कर रही है, वो सब आईपी
पैकेट्स ही होते हैं। एवरीथिंग इज आईपी
पैकेट। बस। अब चलिए
अब आते हैं हम
थोड़ी सी इसमें डीप ड्राइव करते हैं एंड
देन वी विल बी एक्सप्लोरिंग।
चलिए
यहां पे अब मैं कुछ डेफिनेशन के साथ आगे
बढूंगा एंड धीरे-धीरे आपको अदर एस्पेक्ट्स
पे लेके जाऊंगा। अ पैकेट इज द स्मालेस्ट
यूनिट ऑफ डेटा सेंट ओवर अ नेटवर्क। ये
क्या है? एक नॉर्मल सा डेफिनेशन है कि
पैकेट स्मालेस्ट यूनिट ऑफ डेटा होता है।
स्मालेस्ट यूनिट सबसे छोटा यूनिट जो कि एक
नेटवर्क में क्या होता है? भेजा जाता है।
इन मोस्ट कंप्यूटर नेटवर्क्स डेटा इज
ब्रोकन डाउन इंटू स्मॉल यूनिट्स कॉल
पैकेट्स एंड सेंट बिटवीन डिवाइसेस। ठीक
है? अब जो भी एक डेटा होती है जैसे आपने
किसी को ईमेल किया, आपने कोई फाइल भेजी,
कोई फाइल डाउनलोड करी, कोई मैसेज भेजा वो
एक डेटा है। तो डेटा को छोटे-छोटे टुकड़ों
में बांट दिया जाता है। फ्रेगमेंट्स में
बांट दिया जाता है। पैकेट्स जो होते हैं।
एंड इनको भेजा जाता है डिवाइसेस के पास।
जो भी डिवाइसेस के पास इनको ट्रैवल करना
होता है। द सेम होल्ड्स ट्रू ऑन द
इंटरनेट। ईच पैकेट हैज़ अ स्पेसिफिक
स्ट्रक्चर। एक-एक पैकेट का एक स्ट्रक्चर
होता है। मतलब एक डेटा है। डेटा को
पैकेट्स में डिवाइड किया गया। और उस पैकेट
का भी एक स्ट्रक्चर है। छोटे-छोटे पैकेट्स
भी स्ट्रक्चर में आते हैं। आपको बताऊंगा
उसमें बहुत कुछ होता है। डिफाइंड बाय अ
प्रोटोकॉल दैट अलाउस द रेसिपिएंट टू
अंडरस्टैंड द पैकेट्स कंटेंट। इस पैकेट के
अंदर में बहुत सारी इंफॉर्मेशन होती है।
जिस इंफॉर्मेशन की हेल्प से जो उसका
रिसीवर होता है, वो पैकेट के नेचर के बारे
में समझ पाता है। पैकेट किस तरह का है?
इसके अंदर क्या है? उसके बारे में समझ
पाता है। एन IP पैकेट इज़ अ यूनिट ऑफ़ डेटा
इन अ नेटवर्क दैट कंटेंस इनेशन अबाउट द
सोर्स एंड द डेस्टिनेशन एड्रेसेस एंड अदर
कंट्रोल इनेशन नीडेड टू ट्रांसपोर्ट द
पैकेट ओवर अ नेटवर्क। मतलब एक IP पैकेट
में एक IP पैकेट जो कि एक स्मॉल छोटा सा
यूनिट ऑफ़ डेटा स्मालेस्ट यूनिट ऑफ़ डेटा
होता है। उस उसमें क्या होता है? एक सोर्स
एड्रेस की इनेशन होती है, डेस्टिनेशन
एड्रेस की इनेशन होती है और यहां पे
कंट्रोल इनेशन होता है जो कि रिक्वायर्ड
है उस पर्टिकुलर IP पैकेट को एक नेटवर्क
के ऊपर ट्रैवल कराने के लिए। मतलब एक जगह
से दूसरे जगह लेकर जाने के लिए। ठीक है?
तो सोर्स एड्रेस में कहां से वो पैकेट आ
रही है उसकी इनफेशन होती है। डेस्टिनेशन
एड्रेस में इस पैकेट को कहां भेजना है
उसकी इनेशन होती है। एंड द नेक्स्ट इज़
कंट्रोल इनफेशन। कंट्रोल इंफॉर्मेशनेशन जो
होती है उसमें अदर डेटाज़ अदर
इंफॉर्मेशनेशंस होती हैं जो उस पैकेट के
लिए इंपॉर्टेंट होती है पैकेट के
कैरेक्टरिस्टिक्स को बताने के लिए एंड
पैकेट को ट्रांसपोर्ट करने के लिए जो जो
रिक्वायरमेंट है वो सारी चीजें उसके अंदर
होती है। अब यहां पे जो डायग्राम आपको दिख
रहा है ये डायग्राम देख के आपको कंफ्यूज
नहीं होना है। इट्स अ वेरी लें्थी
डायग्राम। आपको दिख रहा होगा अरे यार
क्या-क्या चीजें हैं। कुछ नहीं है। बहुत
सिंपल सा मैटर समझना है कि पैकेट के दो
पार्ट होते हैं। एक पार्ट हेडर हेडर
कहलाता है और एक पार्ट उसका
डेटा यानी टेल या डेटा आप बोल लीजिए। एक
पार्ट उसका डेटा कहलाता है। ठीक है? डेटा
पार्ट जिसमें कि एक्चुअल डेटा होती है या
फिर पेलोड पार्ट आप बोल सकते हैं। तो
पैकेट के दो पार्ट्स हो गए। एक हेडर और एक
पेलोड। बस इतना आप समझ लीजिए। तो पेलोड का
मतलब जो एक्चुअल डेटा पैकेट के अंदर जा
रही है जैसे आपने कोई डेटा कोई फाइल कोई
इमेज कोई टेक्स्ट या कोई ईमेल का कंटेंट
वो डेटा हो गया एक्चुअल डेटा तो वो डेटा
एक पार्ट हो गई और एक होती है हेडर और
हेडर के अंदर में फिर फर्दर सारी इनेशन
होती है जैसे कि सोर्स एड्रेस डेस्टिनेशन
एड्रेस पैकेट की लेंथ हो गई वर्जन हो गया
टाइम टू लेव टीटीएल वैल्यू हो गई
ट्रांसपोर्ट अ मतलब का इनेशन आपका हो गया
हेडर चेक सेक्सम होते हैं वो सारी हो गई।
ये सारी चीजें इसके अंदर होती है। तो दो
पार्ट में होती है। जैसे आप देख सकते हैं
एक पार्ट में आपका पूरा डेटा है और एक
पार्ट में आपका पूरा हेडर है। टोटल ये 32
बिट्स का होता है। एंड यहां पे डेटा में
एक्चुअल डेटा है। एंड यहां पे कुछ पार्ट्स
हैं। ऑप्शंस पैडिंग, डेस्टिनेशन एंड सो
इसमें से कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट चीजें हैं जो
आपको जाननी है। अदर चीजें आपके रिक्वायर्ड
की नहीं है। आप कोई नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
एक्सपर्ट नहीं बनने वाले हो। आपको एसओसी
के व्यू से समझना है, सीखना है। दैट्स इट।
हां अगर आप चाहो तो अदर थिंग्स को आप
एक्सप्लोर जरूर कर सकते हो जो मैं यहां पे
नहीं बताऊंगा जो जरूरी चीजें हैं जो मैं
बताऊंगा उसके अलावा अगर आपको लगता है कि
नहीं मुझे और भी चीजें जाननी है तो आप
बिल्कुल एक्सप्लोर कीजिए खुद से देयर इज़
नो रेस्ट्रिकशंस क्योंकि लर्निंग एंड
नॉलेज लेने की कोई रेस्ट्रिकशंस होनी नहीं
चाहिए एंड आप जितना चाहे उतना एक्सप्लोर
कर सकते हैं। ये आपके लिए अच्छा भी रहता
है। लेकिन यहां पे जितनी रिक्वायरमेंट है
मैं आपको सब चीजें बहुत अच्छे से क्लियर
करके बताऊंगा। ठीक है? अब देखिए
अब आगे चलते हैं। मैंने आपको जैसा कि
बताया कि डेटा को पैकेट्स में ब्रेक किया
जाता है। उनको ट्रांसमिट किया जाता है।
एंड देन फिर रीअेंबल कर दिया जाता है।
डेटा को पैकेट्स में तोड़ा जाता है
छोटे-छोटे टुकड़ों में। उनको वहां से फिर
ट्रांसमिट या ट्रांसपोर्ट किया जाता है।
एंड देन उनको रीअेंबली कर दी जाती है
लास्ट में जो एंड होता है। जब वो जहां पे
पहुंच जाते हैं वहां पे रीअेंबल हो के फिर
से वो पूरा एक पैक मतलब डेटा बन जाते हैं।
ठीक है? अब पैकेट्स में मैंने जैसे बोला
कि एक हेडर और एक पेलोड दो पार्ट होते
हैं। हेडर में कंट्रोल इनफो सारी होती है
और पेलोड में एक्चुअल डेटा होती है जो
ट्रैवल कर रही है। ठीक है? अब देखिए ईच
पैकेट कंटेन्स बोथ डेटा एंड कंट्रोल
इनेशन। एज़ आई सेड द डेटा पोर्शन जो कि एक
पेलोड भी कहा जाता है। कंटेंस द एक्चुअल
कंटेंट बीइंग ट्रांसमिटेड। जो एक्चुअल
कंटेंट ट्रांसमिट हो रहा है। जैसे मैंने
बताया कि टेक्स्ट हो सकती है, इमेज हो
सकती है, वीडियो हो सकता है, किसी भी तरह
का डेटा हो सकता है। व्हाइल द कंट्रोल
इनेशन इज़ द इन द पैकेट हेडर इंक्लूड्स
डिटेल्स सच एज सोर्स एंड डेस्टिनेशन
एड्रेस, टाइम टू लिव, पैकेट लेंथ, राउटिंग
इंस्ट्रशंस ये सारी चीजें होती हैं जो
हमने यहां पे देखा।
हेडर वाले पार्ट में। हेडर वाले पार्ट में
कंट्रोल इनफेशन होती है जिसमें बाकी सारी
इनेशंस होती हैं। बेकार की जो मतलब बेकार
की डेटा नहीं होती। बेकार की इनफेशन नहीं
होती है। बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन होती
है। लेकिन डेटा के अलावा एक्चुअल डेटा के
अलावा ये सारी इनेशन होती है
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
जो आपके किस में होती है? आपके हेडर पार्ट
में होती है। ठीक है?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
यस यस करन राइट। अब देखो इसी में एक चीज
आती है। इसी में एक चीज आती है। एक टर्म
आता है पैकेट इनकैप्सुलेशन। ये एक टर्म
आता है। इसके इस टर्म को याद रखिएगा। ये
टर्म आपके लिए इंपॉर्टेंट हो सकता है
ड्यूरिंग इंटरव्यू क्वेश्चंस ड्यूरिंग
इंटरव्यू राउंड्स जब आप एसओसी के लिए
रहेंगे तो उसमें ये इंपॉर्टेंट रोल प्ले
कर सकता है पैकेट इनकैप्सुलेशन अब देखो ये
क्या होता है जो डेटा होती है ना वो
लेयर्स के थ्रू मूव करती है जैसे मैंने
आपको बताया ओएसआई टीसीपीआईपी राइट तो
टीसीpआईपी लेयर्स प्रैक्टिकल है जो फॉलो
होती है तो उसमें एप्लीकेशन ट्रांसपोर्ट
नेटवर्क डाटा लिंक इस तरीके से ट्रांस
क्या होता है जो डाटा है मूव करती है तो
अब
हर लेयर जो है अपना एक हेडर ऐड कर देता
है। जब भी एक डाटा मूव करती है ना लेयर
वाइज तो हर लेयर अपना एक हेडर ऐड कर देता
है। हेडर का मतलब सिंपल सा फंडा है कि
उसमें बहुत सारी अलग-अलग इनेशन है। जैसे
एचटीटीपी हेडर होती है तो एक वेब
रिक्वेस्ट और वेब रिस्पांस के हेडर्स जो
होते हैं एचटीटीपी हेडर्स उसमें उस
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट या रिस्पांस की इनेशन
होती है। वो रिक्वेस्ट किस तरीके से की जा
रही है? क्या-क्या उसमें सिक्योरिटी
कंट्रोल्स हैं? कहां तक कहां रिक्वेस्ट जा
रही है या कहां कहां से रिस्पांस आ रहा
है। क्या रिस्पांस आ रहा है? किस तरह का
रिस्पांस आ रहा है। ये सारी चीजें होती
है। उसी तरीके से पैकेट भी जब एक लेयर के
थ्रू जो आपका टीसीp लेयर है उसके थ्रू जब
मूव करती है बेसिकली तो उसमें हर एक लेयर
अपना एक हेडर को ऐड कर देता है। ठीक है?
जैसे कि एप्लीकेशन ट्रांसपोर्ट नेटवर्क
डेटा लिंक है तो अब इथरनेट आईपी टीसीp
डेटा ये सारी जो चीजें हैं ये ऐड होती है
हेडर के फॉर्म में कि भैया हां इस इस लेयर
की इस लेयर से हो के आया है फिर इस लेयर
से हो के आया इस लेयर अब इसी चीज को ये जो
एडिशन ऑफ हेडर्स है बाय ईच लेयर्स व्हाइल
डेटा इज़ ट्रैवलिंग थ्रू दीज़ लेयर्स इसको
हम इनकैप्सुलेशन बोलते हैं। इस चीज़ को
थोड़ा समझ लीजिएगा कि इनकैप्सुलेशन का मतलब
सिंपल है कि एडिशन ऑफ़ हेडर्स बाय ईच ऑफ़ द
लेयर्स थ्रू व्हिच द डेटा इज़ ट्रैवलिंग या
मूविंग इन अ कम्युनिकेशन इज़ कॉल्ड
इनकैप्चुलेशन। सिंपल। इसको आप डेफिनेशन
खुद से भी बना सकते हैं। अगर कंसेप्ट
अच्छा हो तो आप डेफिनेशन कांसेप्ट आपका
क्लियर हो तो डेफिनेशन आप खुद से मल्टीपल
डेफिनेशन बना सकते हैं। इट्स टोटली इन योर
हैंड। राइट? दैट्स इट। इसको हम बोलते हैं
पैकेट इनकैप्चुलेशन। इसको थोड़ा सा याद
रखिएगा।
ओके।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब आते हैं
स्ट्रक्चर ऑफ एन आईपी पैकेट पे। स्ट्रक्चर
कैसा होता है? तो हमने यहां पर देखा कि
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एक डेटा होती
है और एक होता है हेडर। अब हेडर डेटा तो
डेटा है। इसके बारे में ज्यादा कुछ आपको
बताने की जरूरत नहीं है। डेटा का मतलब
एक्चुअल डेटा जो ट्रेवल कर रही है जो आपने
टेक्स्ट लिखा है, जो आपने ईमेल भेज रहे
हो, जो आप इमेज, वीडियो, टेक्स्ट भेज रहे
हो वो सब डेटा है। उसके बारे में कुछ बात
करने की बात है नहीं। यहां पे। यहां बात
करने वाली है कि हेडर में जो कुछ
इंपॉर्टेंट फिल्स हैं जैसे डेस्टिनेशन
एड्रेस सोर्स एड्रेस हो गया, टाइम टू लिव
हो गई, वर्जन हो गया, लेंथ हो गया, पैकेट
लेंथ हो गई। ये सब थोड़ा जो है हेडर चेक
सम हो गई। ये सब थोड़ी बहुत जानने की हमें
रिक्वायरमेंट है। तो हम उसी को यहां पे
थोड़ी डिस्कस करने वाले हैं। देखिए सबसे
पहले एक फील्ड होती है हेडर के अंदर में
वर्जन। वर्जन क्या होता है? दिस फील्ड्स
इंडिकेट द आईपी प्रोटोकॉल वर्जन। सिंपल ये
बताता है आईपी का वर्जन कौन सा है? वर्जन
4 एंड वर्जन सिक्स दो हैं। तो, यह बताता
है कि भैया यह वर्जन फोर हैं हमारे कि
वर्जन सिक्स वाले भैया हैं। बस यही बताता
है। कुछ भी नहीं। उसके बाद टोटल लेंथ। अब
ये लेंथ कैसे होता है? ये देखिए।
स्पेसिफाई द पैकेट्स टोटल लेंथ ऑफ द डेटा
पेलोड। ऑफ द डेटा ऑफ द डेटा पेलोड। मतलब
ये क्या बताता है? पैकेट्स का टोटल लेंथ।
ये बताता है आपका टोटल लेंथ। जो भी पैकेट
है उसका टोटल लेंथ ये बताएगा यानी मैसेज
का एंड द हेडर व्हिच आर एसेंशियल फॉर
रिसिपिएंट टू अंडरस्टैंड द पैकेट्स कंटेंट
तो टोटल लेंथ का मतलब होता है कि ये
पैकेट्स का मतलब कि टोटल लेंथ ऑफ द डेटा
पेलोड एंड द हेडर मतलब जो भी हेडर है एंड
जो पेलोड है सिंपल पे दो ही पार्ट होते
हैं एक हेडर पार्ट हो गया एक पेलोड पार्ट
हो गया तो ये पूरा उसका लेंथ बताता है
यानी ये टोटल पैकेट का ही लेंथ बताता है
जो कि जरूरी है पैकेट्स के कंटेंट को
समझने के लिए एट द रिसीवर साइड। रिसीवर
साइड तब पैकेट के कंटेंट को समझ सकते हैं
अगर उनको यह इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाए क्या टोटल
लेंथ। उसके बाद आती है एक इसमें ऑप्शन
प्रोटोकॉल का कि प्रोटोकॉल कौन सा है? तो
ये डिटरमाइन करते हैं प्रोटोकॉल कौन सा
यूज़ हो रहा है इस कम्युनिकेशन में? TCP
यूज़ हो रही है, यूडीपी यूज़ हो रहा है। कौन
सा मतलब पेलोड डाटा पेड में कौन सा
प्रोटोकॉल यूज़ हो रहा है? यह प्रोटोकॉल के
बस देन आता है टाइम टू लिव। अब टाइम टू
लिव को मैं यहां पे अभी स्किप करूंगा
क्योंकि इसके बारे में मैं डिटेल में आज
ही आपको बताने वाला हूं क्योंकि ये इतनी
छोटे में आपको समझ में नहीं आने वाला है।
बाकी चीजें तो आपको समझ में आ जाएगी कि ये
आईपी के वर्जन बताता है। ये आईपी पैकेट का
पूरा लेंथ बताता है। ये प्रोटोकॉल बताता
है। टीसीp एडीपी कौन सा यूज़ हो रहा है।
टाइम टू लीव को समझने के लिए थोड़ा सा
दिमाग लगाना पड़ेगा। मैं आपको एग्जांपल के
थ्रू एंड डिटेल में बताऊंगा तो आपको समझ
में आ जाएगा। अब आते हैं सोर्स IPपी
एड्रेस। तो यह भी बहुत आसान है कि भैया
पैकेट जहां से निकल कर आ रहा है, जहां से
रिक्वेस्ट जो जा रही है, उसका एड्रेस,
उसका IP एड्रेस सिंपल स्पेसिफाई दप एड्रेस
ऑफ़ द डिवाइस दैट डेटा दैट दैट सेंड द
पैकेट। जो पैकेट को सेंड किया है, उसका
एड्रेस सिंपल। डेस्टिनेशन एड्रेस,
आइडेंटिफाई द आईपी एड्रेस ऑफ़ द इंटेंडेंट
रिसीपिएंट ऑफ़ द पैकेट यानी रिसीवर का
एड्रेस। यानी ये पैकेट कहां को जानी है,
किधर डिलीवर करना है, उसका एड्रेस। यानी
मान लो अगर सोर्स आईपी क्लाइंट एड्रेस है
तो डेस्टिनेशन आईपी आपका सर्वर एड्रेस हो
जाएगा। सिंपल क्योंकि अगर सोर्स आईपी पता
नहीं होगी तो बेसिकली सर्वर किस आईपी पर
रिस्पोंड करेगा? अगर सोर्स आईपी ही ना पता
चले सर्वर को पैकेट के अंदर इंफॉर्मेशन ये
ना होती और सर्वर तक ये पैकेट पहुंचता तो
सर्वर जब उस पैकेट की इनेशन को रीड करता,
कंटेंट को रीड करता तो मैसेज तो उसको मिल
जाते। लेकिन उसको ये कैसे पता चलता कि ये
आया कहां से है? और जब उसको ये नहीं पता
चलेगा आया कहां से है? तो वो रिस्पांस जो
भेजेगा सर्वर वो किसको भेजेगा उसको पता ही
नहीं है। इसलिए बहुत जरूरी है टू स्टोर द
सोर्स आईपी इनफेशन इन द पैकेट ताकि
डेस्टिनेशन पे जो डेस्टिनेशन आपका सर्वर
वगैरह है उसको पता चल जाए कि भैया कहां से
है वहीं पे ये रिसोंड कर देंगे। ठीक है?
दैट्स इट। तो ये पूरी इंफॉर्मेशन थी
स्ट्रक्चर आईपी पैकेट के उसके बारे में
डिटेल थी। याद रखिएगा इसमें टाइम टू लिव
आपका बचा हुआ है। यह मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा क्योंकि इतने देर से नहीं होगा। बट
इसको मैं थोड़ा सा यहां पे समझा देता हूं।
इट इज़ यूज़्ड टू प्रिवेंट पैकेट्स फ्रॉम
सर्कुलेटिंग इनडेफिनेटली व्हिच कुड कॉज़
नेटवर्क कंजेशंस।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बस अब इसके
आगे की लाइन आपको समझ में नहीं आएगी तो
मैं नहीं पढ़ रहा हूं क्योंकि वन बाय वन वन
डिक्रीज करना और ये सब अभी आपको वो बाद
में समझ में आएगी। बट अभी इतना समझिए कि
टीटीएल एक ऐसी कांसेप्ट है, एक ऐसा
पर्टिकुलर चीज़ है जो बहुत ज्यादा यूज़फुल
होता है बहुत ज्यादा। एंड अगर टीटीएल ना
हो तो इंटरनेट पे जितने भी पैकेट्स हैं
जैसे आपने कोई एक रिक्वेस्ट भेजी है एक
रिक्वेस्ट कहीं पैकेट ट्रैवल कर रही है तो
बिना टीटीएल का वो रिक्वेस्ट ट्रैवल करता
ही रह जाएगा नेटवर्क के अंदर वो खत्म ही
नहीं होगा रिक्वेस्ट वो रिक्वेस्ट कभी
खत्म एक्स मतलब वो कभी एंड नहीं होगा
एक्सपायर नहीं कुछ नहीं हो सकता वो ऐसे तो
घूमता रहेगा घूमता रहेगा और ऐसे अगर हर
पैकेट होने लगे तो पूरी दुनिया की नेटवर्क
कंजेशन पूरी दुनिया में नेटवर्क कंजेशन हो
जाएगी एक बहुत अच्छा आईडिया भी है नेटवर्क
एक बहुत बड़े लेवल का डीडीओस अटैक करने के
लिए हो पूरे दुनिया के ऊपर अगर
प्रैक्टिकली पॉसिबल हुआ तो बट स्टिल
टीटीएल को अगर वो कर दे तो बट इट्स अ इट्स
इनसाइड द वर्किंग एंड टीएल इसलिए होता है।
अब ये कैसे होता है? क्यों ऐसा होता है?
ये भी हम जानेंगे। इसको जब मैं एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा तो आपको समझ में आ जाएगा कि डिटेल
इज़ वेरीेंट सो दैट कि नेटवर्क कंजेशंस को
बचाया जा सके और पैकेट्स इनडेफिनेटली जो
है वो नेटवर्क में तैरते ना रहे ऐसे घूमते
ना रह जाए। राइट?
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
बिफोर गोइंग टू द टीटीएल कांसेप्ट यहां
आईपी वर्जन फोर के कुछ हेडर फील्ड्स हैं।
जो कि लेयर थ्री नेटवर्क लेयर के अंदर में
आपको मैं कुछ समझाने वाला हूं। इसको थोड़ा
सा आप समझिए। ठीक है? एिल माइंड है। बहुत
बहुत डेंजर हो सकता है ये जैसा यू सेड।
इट [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] कैन बी
वेरी डेंजरस।
अब कुछ IP वर्जन 4 के हेडर फेल्स हैं उनको
हम डिस्कस कर लेते हैं। जैसे कि अभी मैंने
पहले जो मतलब पहले जो यह चीजें बताई आपको
इसको थोड़ा सा एक टेबल के फॉर्म में इसके
एग्जांपल के थ्रू एसओसी यूज़ के थ्रू
समझते हैं। वर्जन वाला क्या बताएगा? वर्जन
कौन सा है? एसओसी का यूज़ केस क्या है? ये
प्रोटोकॉल को आइडेंटिफाई करने के लिए।
सोर्स आईपी क्या? सेंडर के बारे में
बताएगा।
एसओसी का यूज़ क्या है? अटैकर को
आइडेंटिफाई करना। क्योंकि कहां जहां से
अटैक हो रहा है वही तो सोर्स आईपी होगी ना
वहीं की सोर्स आईपी होगी तो अटैकर का ही
तो होगा वो सिंपल
डेस्टिनेशन आईपी ये रिसीवर का होता है
यानी टारगेट सिस्टम एसओसी को इससे पता
चलेगा कि टारगेट सिस्टम कौन सा है किस पे
टारगेट किया जा रहा है टीटीएल पैकेट का
लाइफटाइम यह एनमलीज़ डिटेक्ट करने के लिए
होता है लाइफटाइम पैकेट मतलब कितने देर तक
पैकेट ट्रैवल करेगा कितनी देर तक पैकेट
रहेगा इंटरनेट पे या एक कम्युनिकेशन के
अंदर में ये सारी सारी चीजें प्रोटोकॉल
टीसीपी यूडीपी आईसीएमपी कौन सा प्रोटोकॉल
है यह ट्रैफिक का टाइप बताएगा एसओसी के
लिए टोटल लेंथ पैकेट की पूरी साइज बताएगा
तो यहां पे एक्सफिल्ट्रेशन डिटेक्ट किया
जा सकता है कि अगर पैकेट की साइज बहुत
ज्यादा बड़ी जा रही है बहुत बड़ी साइज की
पैकेट जा रही है या कुछ डाटा जा रहा है तो
समझिए कि कुछ ना कुछ डेटा एक्सफिल्ट्रेट
हो रहा है डेटा चुराया जा रहा है हेडर चेक
सम इंटीग्रिटी का सवाल है करप्शन डिटेक्शन
होती है मतलब इंटीग्रिटी का सवाल है यहां
पे आइडेंटिटी का सवाल है अगर चेक समम में
कोई गड़बड़ी हो रही है हेडर के अंदर इसका
मतलब कुछ गड़बड़ी है। कुछ ना कुछ बीच में
छेड़खानी की गई है उस पर्टिकुलर डेटा
पैकेट के साथ। तो उसको डिटेक्ट किया जाता
है एसओसी के द्वारा। ये एक सिंपल सा टेबल
था जो कि आपको समझाने के लिए मैंने डाला
है। ठीक है?
अब यहां पे टीसीपी हेडर लेयर फोर के मैं
आपसे डिस्कस कर रहा हूं।
जैसे कि लेयर फोर में टीसीपी कुछ हेडर्स
होते हैं। इसमें एक सोर्स पोर्ट,
डेस्टिनेशन पोर्ट यह सारी चीजें होती हैं।
सीक्वेंस नंबर होता है, एसी के नंबर होता
है, फ्लैग्स होते हैं, विंडो साइज होती
है। ये मैं आपको बताऊंगा। हालांकि इसके
बारे में हम अभी आगे भी पढ़ने वाले हैं।
सोर्स पोर्ट में बेसिकली क्या होता है?
सेंडर का जो पोर्ट नंबर होता है, वो पोर्ट
होता है। यह ओरिजिन को आइडेंटिफाई करते
हैं एसओसी के थ्रू। डेस्टिनेशन पोर्ट
टारगेट का सर्विस कौन सा जिसको टारगेट
किया जा रहा है तो यह अटैक को डिटेक्ट
किया जाता है। सीक्वेंस नंबर जो है ऑर्डर
को ट्रैक करने के लिए सेशन एनालिसिस मतलब
हर जो कम्युनिकेशन होती है उसमें एक
सीक्वेंस नंबर होता है। एक सीक्वेंस के
बाद दूसरा कम्युनिकेशन दूसरे सीक्वेंस
तीसरा कम्युनिकेशन ऐसे करके चलता है। तो
उस सीक्वेंस नंबर से ऑर्डर ट्रैकिंग होती
है और सेशन का एनालिस कि कौन सा सेशन है
क्या है वो होता है। एकनॉलेजमेंट नंबर
एकनॉलेज करने का मतलब होता है कंफर्म
करना। जैसे मैंने आपको कुछ पैसे दिए तो
आपने उसको एकनॉलेज किया। तो आपने बोला यस
आई एम एकनॉलेजिंग दैट यू आर गिविंग मी दिस
मनी। इसका मतलब यू आर एक्सेप्टिंग दैट यू
गॉट द मनी। तो ये कन्फर्मेशन को डिसकली
शो के शो करता है। एंड यहां पे फ्लो का
वैलिडेशन होता है। ये फ्लो को वैलिडेट
करता है कि भैया हां अब एक कम्युनिकेशन हो
गई दूसरी। दूसरी तीसरी चौथी ऐसे करके।
फ्लैग्स। अब ये जो होते हैं कनेक्शन के
स्टेट को बनाते हैं। जैसे कि दो डिवाइसेस
के बीच में कम्युनिकेशन हो रही है तो उनका
कनेक्शन स्टेट क्या है? उसको बताती है। तो
देयर आर फ्लैग्स देयर आर सम टीसीपी
फ्लैग्स जिसके बारे में भी हम जानेंगे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] उनके थ्रू
पता चलता है कि ये कनेक्शन जो है वो किस
पर्टिकुलर स्टेट में है। मतलब कम्युनिकेशन
के स्टेट में है या रुक गई है या अभी डेटा
फ्लो स्टार्ट होने वाला है या क्या होने
वाला है। तो वो स्टेट को बताती है
फ्लैग्स। एंड फिर रहता है विंडो साइज जो
कि फ्लो के कंट्रोल को बताता है। ट्रैफिक
बिहेवियर पता चलता है कि भैया किस तरह की
ट्रैफिक है। क्या किस तरीके का इनका
बिहेवियर है ट्रैफिक का। ये सारी चीजें
बताती है। तो फ्लो जो है ट्रैफिक का जो
डेटा का उसके बारे में बताती है। ठीक है?
ओके। ये तो एक टेबल था जो आपको बताना था।
अब यहां पे आते हैं इसके बेसिकली एक
एग्जांपल पैकेट के ऊपर आते हैं। एसोसिएट
एनालिसिस करते हैं उसका। फिर हम आगे
बढ़ेंगे। जैसे एक पैकेट है मान लो जिसमें
सोर्स आईपी दी हुई है, डेस्टिनेशन IPपी दी
हुई है, प्रोटोकॉल दिया हुआ है, डीटीएल
वैल्यू दी हुई है, लेंथ दिया हुआ है। अब
देखो इससे क्या पता चल रहा है? इससे पता
चल रहा है सोर्स आईपी जो कि 192 168 अगर
आपने क्लासेस ऑफ़ IPपी एड्रेस वाली क्लास
देखी हो उसको थोड़ा सा दिमाग में अगर हो तो
ये एक इंटरनल IPपी को डिनोट कर रहा है। ये
हमारा इंटरनल IP है। बट डेस्टिनेशन क्या
है? 45.77
यानी कि यह एक एक्सटर्नल वैन IP को डिनोट
कर रहा है। बाहर का एक IP है। इंटरनल
नेटवर्क का IP नहीं है यह। तो ये बाहर के
आईपी को डिनोट कर रहा है। तो इंटरनल आईपी
सोर्स आईपी है चलेगा। एक्सटर्नल के तरफ
रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है। तो ये सस्िशियस है
कि भैया इंटरनल से एक्सटर्नल की तरफ कहां
जा रही है रिक्वेस्ट? प्रोटोकॉल है TCP
ओके चलेगा। TTL अपना 64 वैल्यू है। लेंथ
इज़ 1500 बाइट्स। तो कुछ खास इतना भी बड़ा
साइज नहीं है लेंथ का तो ये भी चलेगा। तो
नोन सर्विस है अगर तब तो सही है। अगर ये
जो कनेक्शन हो रही है पैकेट की अगर वो एक
नोन सर्विस हो रही है फिर सही है। लेकिन
अननोन या मलिश सर्विस है तो वहां पे अलर्ट
आएगा आपको। तो ये चीजें होती हैं बेसिकली
एसओसी के एक एसओसी के तौर पे आपको ये
चीजें थोड़ी सी ध्यान में रखनी है। जब भी
कोई रिक्वेस्ट होती है तो उसको थोड़ा
ध्यान में देखना है कि सोर्स आईपी किस तरह
की है? क्या है? डेस्टिनेशन आईपी कहां जा
रही है रिक्वेस्ट? प्रोटोकॉल कौन सा यूज़
हो रहा है? है टीटीएल वैल्यू कोई
अनएक्सेक्टेड वैल्यू तो नहीं है टीटीएल की
या लेंथ बहुत ऐसी तो नहीं कि बहुत बड़ी
कोई लेंथ की डाटा जा रही हो या
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन जा रही हो तो ये सब चीजें
थोड़ा मॉनिटर करना एसओसी का काम होता है
एसओसी का काम है इन्वेस्टिगेशन करना
इन्वेस्टिगेटर है वो एक तरह का वो एक तरह
का साइबर अटैक का इन्वेस्टिगेटर है जैसे
साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेटर होते हैं
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक इन्वेस्टिगेटर होते हैं
वैसे ही होता है हां डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक से
मुझे याद आ गया आप सबको बता देता हूं अभी
मेरे दिमाग से ये चीज निकल गई थी बट अभी
अभी क्योंकि मैंने नाम लिया तो मेरे को
याद आया ये कि
डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स की एक लाइव ट्रेनिंग जो
है वो ल्च हो रही है। ऑलरेडी प्री बुकिंग
एनरोलमेंट चालू हो गई थी। YouTube पे
अनाउंसमेंट भी आ चुका है। आप सबको शायद
बहुत लोगों को पता भी होगा। इस तो आप वैसे
तो अगर चाहे तो आप अनाउंसमेंट एंड डिटेल
वाली जो वीडियो है ऑलरेडी डली हुई है
YouTube पे। तो आप चैनल पे जाके वीडियो
सेक्शन में चले जाइएगा। एंड यह जो वीडियो
है डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स बिकम अ डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक डीडीएफएस इसको देख लीजिएगा।
स्कीम में सारी डिटेल है। इनरोलमेंट के
लिंक है। सब कुछ है। बट यह ट्रेनिंग परसों
से ही स्टार्ट हो रही है। 18 अप्रैल से
काफी टाइम पहले से यह चल रही थी इनरोलमेंट
एंड ऑल। तो अगर आप इसमें आना चाहते हैं तो
बिल्कुल आप आइए कल तक का टाइम है एनरोल
करने का। एंड जो भी ऑफर फी या जो भी चीजें
हैं आप इस पर आकर देख सकते हैं। अभी
फिलहाल ऑफर में ही चल रहा है। एंड डाउनलोड
द ब्रश पे करके आप इसकी पूरी मॉड्यूल और
ये सारी चीजें देख सकते हैं। क्या-क्या
टॉपिक्स हैं सारी चीजें हैं। स्पेशली
एसओसी वालों के लिए बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है।
क्योंकि देखो एसओसी का पार्ट एसओसी एज अ
एसओसी आपको डिजिटल फॉरेंसिक्स तो सीखना ही
पड़ेगा। चाहे कुछ भी हो जाए आपको सीखना
पड़ेगा। तो आप चाहे तो ऑनलाइन फ्री में
कहीं से रिसोर्सेज ले सीख सकते हैं। वो
आपकी मर्जी है। बट अगर स्ट्रक्चरर्ड एक वे
में हमारी क्वालिटी आपको पता है थोड़ा सा
एक डेप्थ इन डेप्थ हो के सीखना है आपको तो
आप इसके साथ जा सकते हैं। क्योंकि एसओसी
एल2 जो रोल होता है एल2 उसके लिए डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक्स इज़ वेरी वेरीेंट। उसमें आपको
आना ही आना। मतलब वो मैंडेटरी स्केल है
आपके लिए। तो आप चाहें तो इसमें आ सकते
हैं। बट कल तक का ही टाइम है। याद रखिएगा।
परसों से एनरोलमेंट तो वैसे भी क्लोज हो
जाएगी। परसों से क्लासेस हैं। तो कल तक आप
चाहें तो एनरोल कर सकते हैं। ज्यादा डिटेल
के लिए वीडियो देख लीजिएगा एंड इसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन लिंक पिन कमेंट में सब आपको
मिल जाएगा। ठीक है? थैंक यू वेरी मच। बट
एसओसी वालों के लिए बहुत जरूरी है। तो अगर
आप चाहें तो आप जरूर इसमें आइएगा। ओके?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
फॉरेंसिक्स के WhatsApp ग्रुप में कल तक
ऐड हो जाएंगे सभी लोग। ओके। तो ये आपको
समझ में अब आ चुका होगा जो यहां पे मैंने
आपको बताया। ठीक है? अब नेक्स्ट चलते हैं।
अब आते हैं हमारे टीडीटीएल के ऊपर में।
ठीक है? नाउ इट्स अह अह टीडीटीएल।
ठीक है। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हां जी। हां जी। हां जी। प्रैक्टिकल सब
होगा यार। सारे होंगे। सारे होंगे।
टीडीटीएल। टीटीएल का फुल फॉर्म होता है
टाइम टू लिव। इसका फुल फॉर्म होता है टाइम
टू लिव। इसके फुल फॉर्म से आपको समझ में आ
रहा होगा। एक टाइम इतना वह टाइम जो कि
जिंदा रहने के लिए बताया जा रहा है। मतलब
एक टाइम जब तक कि यह चीज एकिस्ट करेगी।
टाइम टू लिव बस। अब देखिए टीटीएल रेफर्स
टू द अमाउंट ऑफ टाइम। अमाउंट ऑफ टाइम और
हॉप्स
दैट अ पैकेट इज सेट टू एग्जिस्ट इनाइड अ
नेटवर्क बिफोर बीइंग डिस्कारेड बाय अ
राउटर।
देखो
हॉप क्या होता है?
एक डाटा पैकेट
मुझे एक चीज सिनेरियो आई थिंक समझ में आ
रहा होगा आप लोगों को पता होगा। देखो जब
एक डेटा पैकेट एक नेटवर्क से निकलती है
बाहर की दुनिया में जैसे आपके इंटरनल
नेटवर्क से जैसे मेरे यहां पे मैं यहां पे
वाई-फाई यूज़ कर रहा हूं। मैं यहां से
google.com ओपन करूंगा। ठीक है? मान लो
यहां से google.com ओपन कर रहा हूं मैं
ब्राउज़र में। तो होता क्या है कि मेरे
नेटवर्क से मतलब मेरे राउटर के थ्रू मेरी
रिक्वेस्ट बाहर किसी और बाहर की तरफ निकल
रही है। अब बाहर की तरफ निकलेगी ना तो
सिर्फ मेरे राउटर से डायरेक्ट Google तक
नहीं पहुंच जाएगी। वह मल्टीपल राउटर्स से
होते हुए Google तक पहुंचती है। मल्टीपल
राउटर से यानी मल्टीपल डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट
अदर सर्वर्स से होते हुए वो Google मेन
सर्वर तक पहुंच जाती है। अब इसमें जो
मल्टीपल राउटर्स बीच में आते हैं तो एक
राउटर से दूसरे राउटर तक जो डेटा ट्रैवल
कर रही है जो डेटा कूद के जाती है उसी को
हम हॉप में मेजर करते हैं।
फ़ ट्रैवलिंग फ्रॉम वन राउटर टु अनदर
राउटर। डाटा डाटा की जो ट्रैवलिंग होती
है, उसको हॉप में मेज़ किया जाता है। वहीं
यह हॉप यहां पे बोला जा रहा है। तो, टाइम
टू लिव रेफर्स टू द अमाउंट ऑफ टाइम और
हॉप्स।
ठीक है? कितने हॉप्स हुए हैं या कितना
टाइम हुआ है? दैट अ पैकेट इज़ सेट टू
एग्जिस्ट। कि एक पैकेट को एक पैकेट को
एग्जिस्ट करने का टाइम इनाइड अ नेटवर्क
बिफोर डिस्कारेड बाय राउटर। मतलब एक डाटा
पैकेट राउटर उसको ड्रॉप कर दे। उसके पहले
कितने टाइम तक वह रह रहा है एक नेटवर्क के
अंदर में। कितने राउटर्स कूद चुका है? वो
वो बताता है टाइम टू लिफ्ट। सिंपल। अब बात
यहां आती है कि राउटर क्यों डेटा पैकेट को
ड्रॉप करेगा? तो यहीं पे टीटीएल का
कांसेप्ट है कि अगर राउटर डेटा पैकेट्स को
ड्रॉप नहीं करेंगे तो फिर वो तो डेटा
पैकेट एक तो इनडेफिनेट डेटा पैकेट्स
नेटवर्क में आ जाएंगे। इनफाइनाइट डेटा
पैकेट्स नेटवर्क में होंगे। सारे लोगों को
इधरउधर मेरा आपका सबका और वह कभी भी ड्रॉप
नहीं होंगे कभी भी डिस्कार्ड नहीं होंगे
उनको मारा नहीं जाएगा तो फिर वो तो सोचो
जस्ट इमेजिन द सिचुएशन पैकेट पैकेट की जगह
पे मैं यहां पे ह्यूमंस को रखता हूं अब
अर्थ पे ह्यूमंस की या किसी भी लिविंग
ऑर्गेनिज्म का क्या है कि एक लिविंग
ऑर्गेनिज्म जिसका जन्म होता है उसकी
मृत्यु निश्चित है।
मनुष्य के केस में मनुष्य का भी जन्म होता
है तो उसकी मृत्यु निश्चित है। अगर मनुष्य
जो है उसकी मृत्यु ना हो और वह जिंदा ही
रह जाए हमेशा के लिए तो क्या धरती उसके
भार को संभाल पाएगी? नहीं। सारे जो
रिसोर्सेज हैं एग्जॉस्ट हो जाएंगे। नेचर
खत्म हो जाएगा। राइट? इवन मनुष्य की
छोड़ो। मनुष्य की छोड़ो। एक जानवर की मैं
बात करता हूं। एनिमल्स की बात कर रहा हूं।
ठीक है? तो कोई भी एनिमल भी अगर सिर्फ मरे
ना जिंदे जिंदा ही रह जाए तो क्या आप रह
सकते हैं धरती पे? इन केस ऑफ़ स्नेक्स मान
लो लेयर पार्ट्स या
आप टाइगर, लायन या कोई बर्ड ही मान लो वो
मरे ही ना। तो समझो कि देयर विल बी
अबंडेंस एंड रह नहीं सकता कोई और।
राइट? यह नॉर्मल सा सीन है। तो यहां पे
उसी तरीके से पैकेट्स को भी खत्म होना
होता है। लेकिन उसका एक क्राइटेरिया होता
है कि किस क्राइटेरिया पर वह खत्म होगा।
ठीक है? तो यहां पे टीटीएल उसी के यूज़ में
आ रहा है। TTL इज़ आल्सो यूज़्ड इन अदर
कॉन्टेक्स्ट इंक्लूडिंग सीडीएन कैशिंग एंड
डीएनएस कैशिंग। सीडीएन कैशिंग जो कंटेंट
डिलीवरी नेटवर्क की कैशिंग होती है या
डीएनएस डोमेन नेम सिस्टम की कैशिंग होती
है। इसमें भी कैशिंग में होता है। ये इसका
यूज़ होता है। बट कैसे क्या वो बाद में
देखेंगे। बट फिलहाल हम समझते हैं कि ये
TTL एक्चुअली काम कैसे करता है। किस तरीके
से ये ऑपरेट करता है। चलो पहले मैं आपको
एग्जांपल दिखाऊंगा एंड देन मैं आपके इसके
कांसेप्ट पे आऊंगा। ठीक है? क्योंकि बिना
एग्जांपल दिखाए कांसेप्ट को समझने में
आपको दिक्कत आएगी। मैं यहां पे सीएमडी ओपन
कर लेता हूं। ठीक है?
मैं सीएमडी ओपन कर रहा हूं। अब मैं
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] क्या करता
हूं? एक कमांड चलाता हूं जो कि TTL
बेसिकली TTL की अभी बात नहीं करता हूं।
मैं फिलहाल के लिए आपको सिर्फ एक पिंग
कमांड चलाता हूं और google.com को पिंग
करता हूं। बेसिकली पिंग कमांड किस लिए यूज़
में आता है? आप सबको पता होगा यहां पे।
चलो मैं यहां पे
नहीं आ रहा है। टी टी फिर से करते हैं।
चलो मैं हफन 4 लगा देता हूं।
हम [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां पे आ गया। तो IP वर्जन 4 मिल गई
मुझे। मैंने Google को पिंग किया है टू
चेक इफ द Google होस्ट इज़ रीचेबल ऑ नॉट।
पिंग कमांड का यूज़ करते हैं। कोई भी होस्ट
रीचेबल है कि नहीं, अप है कि नहीं, काम कर
रहा है कि नहीं? यह मोस्टली देखते हैं। बट
पिंग इज़ अ आईसीएमपी प्रोटोकॉल। पिंग इज़
बेस्ड ऑन आईसीएमपी प्रोटोकॉल। अब क्या है
वो आपको बताया हुआ है ऑलरेडी। TCP,
यूडीपी, आईसीएमपी। एक एक एरर बेस्ड एरर
मैकेनिज्म को चेक करने के लिए एक
प्रोटोकॉल होता है। किसी भी तरह की एरर
हैंडलिंग जो है वो आईसीएम प्रोटोकॉल की
तरफ से किया जाता है या रिपोर्टिंग वगैरह
हो गई। तो पिंग जो है मैंने किया
google.com अभी आ रहा है पिंग google.com
यहां IP आ रही है विद 32 बाइट्स ऑफ़ डेटा आ
रहा है। ठीक है? यह 32 बिट्स ऑफ बाइट्स ऑफ
डाटा Windows के केस में है। Linux में 64
आई थिंक होता है। तो डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स के लिए अलग-अलग होते
हैं। ठीक है? अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे तो
पहली लाइन जो आ रही है, दूसरी लाइन जो आ
रही है, इसको देखिए। देखिए, रिप्लाई फ्रॉम
ये रिप्लाई आ रहा है Google से। बाइट्स 32
पैकेट की लेंथ है जो भी है। आ गई। ठीक है?
टाइम 5 मिली सेकंड्स का लग रहा है। यह जो
टाइम है यह मैं आपको बताऊंगा क्या यह कौन
सी टाइम होती है। बेसिकली यह आपका एवरेज
टाइम है एक तरह का
जिसको बोलते हैं राउंड ट्रिप टाइम बोलते
हैं आरटीटी। मैं बहुत डीप में नहीं जाऊंगा
अभी नहीं तो आप कंफ्यूज हो जाएंगे। तो
यहां पे एक टर्म है आपको टीटीएल जो कि
आपको फिक्स नंबर एक दिख रहा है 119।
यही टीटीएल वैल्यू की बात हो रही है। टाइम
टू लिव की। अब ये TTL वैल्यू जो होती है
ये Windows में अलग होते हैं। Linux में
अलग होते हैं। Mac OS में अलग होते हैं।
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वाइज़ होते हैं। बट एक
फिक्स्ड नंबर होता है। Windows में मतलब
जनरली क्या 64 128 119 मतलब
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट नंबर्स होते हैं। ठीक है?
256 तो ये जो टीएल वैल्यू है ये आपके
पर्टिकुलर जैसे ही आपने रिक्वेस्ट भेजा
वहां पे असाइन होती है वैल्यू और वो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वाइज़ डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट
वैल्यूज़ होते हैं। ठीक है? वो फिक्स नंबर
एक होता है। ये असाइन हो जाती है। तो यहां
पे डिटेल वैल्यू जो फिक्स हुई है असाइन
हुई है वो 119
असाइन हुई है। या 119 हमें मिला है। अब
इसका मतलब क्या है? एग्जैक्टली क्या हो
रहा है? और यहां पे आपको सिर्फ चार
रिक्वेस्ट गई है। एक दो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तीन चार। यहां पे आपकी चार रिक्वेस्ट्स जो
है ओनली गई है इस टीडीएल में इस पर्टिकुलर
चीज में। अब देखो यहां पे मैं क्या
करूंगा?
इफ इट्स वर्किंग लेट्स सी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम मैंने यहां पे इसी सेम कमांड में हफन
टी लगा दिया। हफन टी यहां पे तो ये जो
पर्टिकुलर रिस्पांस है ये चलता जाएगा
लinक्स की तरह। जैसे लinक्स में क्या है?
रिस्पोंस जब आप करेंगे हफन T बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट
आपका वहां पे वो चलता रहता है। ये रुकेगा
नहीं। चार ही रिक्वेस्ट नहीं है। ये
मल्टीपल रिक्वेस्ट जो है आपको यहां पे
करता रहेगा। पिंग करता रहेगा। ये मतलब
इसको पिंग करता रहेगा। इसकी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
लेता रहेगा कि भैया हम वहां तक पहुंच पा
रहे हैं कि नहीं पहुंच पा रहे हैं। हो पा
रहा है कि नहीं कुछ हो पा रहा है। ऐसे
करके अब यहां पे तो आपने पिंग का देख
लिया। मैंने तो पिंग का यहां पे कर दिया।
अब पिंग का जब आप एंड करोगे तो लास्ट में
आपको दिखेगा टोटल सेंट पैकेट कितने थे? 34
यानी 34 टाइम्स रिक्वेस्ट गई है। ऊपर में
फोर होंगे। देखो टोटल सेंट पैकेट्स फोर
है। क्योंकि यहां पे हमने रिकर्सिव मतलब
इनफाइनाइट वाला नहीं कर रहा था। सिंपल सा
रिकर्सिव कि हां चलता रहे, रिक्वेस्ट जाता
रहे। यहां पे हमने सिर्फ डिफ़ॉल्ट किया था।
था। तो डिफ़ॉल्ट में चार ही होते हैं
जनरली। तो यहां पे चार बार रिक्वेस्ट गई
है। तो यहां पे टोटल पैकेट जो सेंट है वो
चार थे। रिसीव्ड टोटल चार है क्योंकि
चारों के रिप्लाई आ गए हैं। लॉस पैकेट
ज़ीरो है। यानी कि पैकेट का जो लॉस है वो
नहीं हुआ है किसी भी तरह का। अब
एप्रोक्समेट राउंड ट्रिप टाइम्स इन मिली
सेकंड्स। यहां पे अप्रोक्समेट राउंड ट्रिप
टाइम। यानी कि एक जो रिक्वेस्ट एक पैकेट
की रिक्वेस्ट जो है वो गई और वहां से जो
हमें रिस्पांस आया वो राउंड ट्रिप टाइम हो
गया। मैंने यहां से रिक्वेस्ट करा कि भैया
Google जिंदा हो? Google ने बोला हां हां
मैं जिंदा हूं। लो रिप्लाई। तो इसको हम
बोलते हैं जा के आने वाले को राउंड ट्रिप
टाइम आरटीटी। तो इसका एवरेज आरटीटी क्या
मिला? 4 मिलीसे। यानी कि 4 मिसे्स का
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
टाइम लग रहा है। क्योंकि कभी ये पांच ले
रहा था। किसी रिक्वेस्ट में पांच, किसी
में चार, किसी में पांच। तो एवरेज 4
मि.सेकंड लगा। अब यहां पे देखते हैं यहां
पे [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] पैकेट 34
सेंट हुए हैं। रिसीव्ड भी 34 हुए। लॉस
ज़ीरो इसमें भी हुआ है। एवरेज जो है इसका
मैक्सिमम टाइम जो लगा है 12 मिलीसे का लगा
है। रिक्वेस्ट को पहुंचने में मिनिमम टाइम
4 मिलीसे को लगा। अब देखो इसका रीज़ क्या
है मैं आपको बताता हूं। देखो
हमारी पहली जो रिक्वेस्ट गई है उसको सिर्फ
5 मिलीसे्स लगे हैं जाके आने में। मतलब
रिक्वेस्ट गई और फिर वापस से रिक्वेस्ट आ
गई। तो इसमें जस्ट 5 मिली सेकंड्स
यूटिलाइज हुआ है। लेकिन दूसरे रिक्वेस्ट
में 12 मिलीसे लगे। यानी फाइव के अगर
कंपैरिजन में देखा जाए तो 12 तो बहुत
ज्यादा है। हालांकि है तो मिली सेकंड्स
में ही बहुत ही कम है। बट फाइव के
रेस्पेक्ट में 12 12 इज़ वेरी वेरी वेरी
बिग नंबर। तो ऐसा क्यों हो सकता? ऐसा
क्यों? क्योंकि जब यह रिक्वेस्ट गई है तो
दूसरी रिक्वेस्ट जब गई है तो हो सकता है
जिस राउटर के थ्रू गई होगी ना वहां पे कुछ
इशू कंजेशन या कुछ भी होगा रिस्पांस टाइम
बढ़ गया होगा रिस्पांस देने में टाइम लगा
होगा इस वजह से ट्रैवलिंग टाइम जो बढ़ी
उसकी वजह से यहां पे आरटीटी आपका बढ़ गया
है तो ये 12 मिलीसे हो गया फिर तीसरे में
फिर कम हो गई ऐसे फिर कोई खास इशू नहीं
फिर इस वाले राउटर पे देखो 9 मिलीसे थोड़ा
ज्यादा लग गया है तो यहां पे फिर कुछ इशू
हुआ तो ये तो आपने पिंक के थ्रू समझा यहां
पे टीटीएल वैल्यू एक होती है लेकिन अब
इसको थोड़ा हम और और भी ज्यादा क्लेरिटी
के साथ समझेंगे। एक और कमांड से जो कि इस
चीज को समझाने में ज्यादा अच्छा आपको
दिखाएगी वो है ट्रेस
आरटी कमांड। अब ये कमांड लinक्स में ट्रेस
रूट कमांड से होता है। Macos में ट्रेस
रूट कमांड होता है। Windows में ट्रेस
आरटी कमांड होती है। जिसका मतलब है रूट को
ट्रेस करना। यानी एक पैकेट एक जगह से
दूसरे जगह जो ट्रैवल कर रही है उसकी पूरी
रूट को यह ट्रेस करता है। ये पूरी रूट को
ट्रेस करता है। तो मैं अब क्या करता हूं
यहां पे दो आपको एग्जांपल के थ्रू समझाता
हूं। मैंने ट्रेस आरटी किया और मैं यहां
पे Google का रूट ट्रेस करता हूं। पहले तो
मैंने ट्रेस आरटी किया एंड एंटर किया। अब
देखो यहां पे क्या हो रहा है। जस्ट सी
व्हाट इज़ हैपनिंग हियर।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
देखो ट्रेस आरटी हो रही है google.com
यहां पर IP वर्जन सिक्स यहां पर आ रही है।
आपको दिख रहा होगा वर्जन 4 नहीं है। वर्जन
सिक्स है तो वर्जन सिक्स पे ही लेके चलते
हैं। नो इशज़।
अब देखिए हो गया ये। अब यहां पे
देखिए मैं आपको पहले ही बताता हूं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यह जो रिक्वेस्ट है
Google के रूट की है।
थैंक्स साइबर पिक्सल। Google के रूट की
है। Google की यहां पर आईपी वर्जन सिक्स
मिली है। याद रखिए जो लास्ट रिक्वेस्ट
ट्रेस हुई है इसके भी आईपी सेम एग्जैक्ट
वही है जो यहां ऊपर हमें मिली है। यानी
Google की आईपी यानी कि ये रिक्वेस्ट
Google तक पहुंच चुकी है। एंड सक्सेसफुली
आपका रूट ट्रेस हो चुका है। लेकिन इसमें
कुछ इशूज़ हैं। क्या हुआ? यह जो 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 आपको यह जो नंबर्स दिखा रहे हैं
यह दिखा रहे हैं कितने राउटर्स
के थ्रू होते हुए ये रिक्वेस्ट गई है। तो
यहां पे नाइन राउटर्स यूज़ हुए हैं। यानी
कि आपके यानी कि मेरे नेटवर्क से ये
रिक्वेस्ट जब निकली है मेरे राउटर से तो
आठ और जैसे देखो ये मान लो पहला जो राउटर
है मान लो ये मेरा राउटर है। दिस इज़ द माय
फर्स्ट राउटर। ठीक है? इसको मैं IP
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वर्जन 4 में
देखता हूं अगर मिल जाए तो। अभी भी सेम IB
वर्जन 4 में आई थिंक मुश्किल है कि IP
वर्जन 4 में मिलेगी इसलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] देखते हैं।
हां, ठीक है, मिल रही है। IP वर्जन 4 में
भी मिल रही है। तो IPO वर्जन 4 में मैं
आपको समझाता हूं। यह ज्यादा आपको
अच्छे से समझ में आएगा। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हफन 4 से भी ओनली हो जाता है। हफन V4 का
मतलब नहीं है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है। चलो वर्जन फोर से ही देखते हैं।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलो यहां ये और भी अच्छा हुआ। हमने वर्जन
4 को जब किया तो ये अच्छा हुआ। मैं आपको
अच्छे से थोड़ा सा एग्जांपल के थ्रू समझा
सकता हूं। देखो दोनों वर्जन को हम समझेंगे
कि इसमें क्या हुआ है। इसमें आप देखोगे ये
जो ट्रेिंग हुई है आईपी वर्जन 4 वाली में
ट्रेस रूट कमांड से तो यहां पे 1 2 3 4 आठ
राउटर्स आपको दिख रहे हैं। ऊपर जो हुई थी
यहां पे नौ दिख रहे हैं। नीचे वाले में
कोई भी स्टार एस्टेरिक्स जो मार्क वाली
रिक्वेस्ट है वो नहीं है। मतलब एस्टेरिस्क
वाली कोई भी रिक्वेस्ट नहीं गई है। यहां
पे आपको एक सेकंड राउटर जो है इसमें आपको
दिखेगा रिक्वेस्ट टाइम आउट एस्टेरिस्क
मार्क दिखेंगे तीनों फील्ड्स में। ठीक है?
अब गाइज देखो यहां पे जो होते हैं ना तीन
फील्ड्स होते हैं। एक दो तीन ये तीन
फील्ड्स क्या होते हैं आपको? पता है क्या
किसी को? ये तीनों क्या है? ये एनीवन कैन
टेल मी व्हाट आर दी थ्री थिंग्स? बताइए
मुझे। ये तीनों क्या है? एक्सैक्टली बताइए
मुझे।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आई एम वेटिंग फॉर द आंसर इफ समवन कैन गिव
कोई भी बताओ एनीवन
क्या है ये
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
नहीं नहीं ये तीनों जो है तीन पैकेट्स को
डिनोट करते हैं। ये तीनों तीन पैकेट्स को
डिनोट करते हैं। यानी कि यहां पे तीन
पैकेट्स को भेजे जा रहे हैं।
तीन पैकेट्स को थ्री पैकेट्स आर बीइंग
सेंट। ठीक है? ये तीनों ये जो है तीन
पैकेट्स को डिनोट किया जा रहा है और एक जो
टाइम है वो एक पैकेट का राउंड ट्रिप टाइम
बता रहा है 2 मिलीसे दूसरे पैकेट का 1
मिसेंड तीसरे पैकेट का 2 मिसे अब समझ में
आ रहा है
समझ में अब आ रहा है पहला पैकेट 2 मिलीसे
में का राउंड ट्रिप टाइम है दूसरे पैकेट
का 1 मिलीसे का राउंड ट्रिप टाइम है तीसरे
पैकेट का 2 मिलीसे का राउंड ट्रिप टाइम है
यानी कि पहला पैकेट 2 मिली सेकंड ले रहा
है, जा रहा है, इंक्वायरी करके आ रहा है।
फिर दूसरा 1 मिली, फिर तीसरा 2 मिलीसे।
ठीक है? गॉट इट? तो ये तीन पैकेट्स को
डिनोट करते हैं। यहां तीन पैकेट्स भेजे जा
रहे हैं बैच में।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ठीक है? अब देखो
पहला रिक्वेस्ट तो गया इस इस वाले में
देखते हैं। आईपी वर्जन सिक्स वाले में।
दूसरे में ये एस्टेरिस्क मार्क है।
रिक्वेस्ट टाइम आउट आ रहा है। इसका मतलब
ये नहीं है कि कनेक्शन फेल हो चुकी है।
इसका मतलब है इस पर्टिकुलर राउटर के लिए।
ठीक है? कुछ ना कुछ इशूज़ है उस राउटर के
पास हुए होंगे। उस राउटर के थ्रू जब
रिक्वेस्ट गई थी तो वहां कुछ इशूज़ क्रिएट
हुए होंगे। या तो वो रिक्वेस्ट उसने ड्रॉप
कर दिया होगा। बट अगर ऐसी जब रिक्वेस्ट
जाती है, ऐसी जब कमांड जाती है तो जब
पैकेट को ट्रैस ट्रेस किया जाता है तो वो
ट्रेिंग जो चीज आपको मैकेनिज्म है वो कैसे
काम करती है कि अगर एक राउटर के पास गई
उसने उसको आंसर दे दिया कि हां भैया मैं
हूं मेरे थ्रू जाओ मेरे थ्रू ये रूट है
दूसरे राउटर के पास गया और उसने अगर कोई
भी रिस्पांस नहीं दिया ड्यू टू एनी काइंड
ऑफ़ थिंग कोई फायर वाल हो सकती है किसी तरह
का कोई मैल फंक्शनिंग हो सकता है किसी तरह
का कोई डिले हो सकता है या हो सकता है
उसको को ब्लॉक कर दिया। उस पर्टिकुलर
रिक्वेस्ट को ब्लॉक कर दिया जाए या ड्रॉप
कर दिया हो। कुछ भी हो सकता है। उस केस
में यहां पे एस्टेरिस्क मार्क आ जाएगा। हो
सकता है कि ये एक पैकेट के लिए एस्टेरिस
का है। दूसरे के लिए तीसरे के लिए ना आए।
ऐसा भी हो सकता है कि एक पैकेट ना पहुंच
पाए वहां तक दूसरा तीसरा पहुंच जाए। या एक
दो पहला दूसरा ना पहुंच पाए, तीसरा पहुंच
जाए। ऐसा भी है। पहला तीसरा पहुंच जाए,
दूसरा ना तो ऐसे सिनेरियो हो सकते हैं। तो
उस केस में अगर जो पहुंच जाएगा उसके पास
मिलीसेकंड का टाइम आपको दिखा देगा। जो
नहीं पहुंचेगा एस्टेरिस्क यानी स्टार
मार्क आपको दिखा दिया जाएगा। दैट्स इट। तो
अब यहां पे तीन एस्टरिस का मतलब यहां पे
हो जाता है कि तीनों पैकेट्स जो हैं वो
बेचारे उनको कुछ जवाब नहीं मिला है उस
राउटर से। तो वो फिर पास ऑन हो जाते हैं
अलग दूसरे राउटर पे और उसके राउटर का यहां
पे एस्टेरिस्टिक्स दिखा देते हैं और वो
फिर तीसरे राउटर वाले का यहां पे आपको
बताने लगते हैं कि 7 मिसे 4 मिसे 2
मिलीसे। एंड इनकी आईपी यहां पे शो हो जाती
है। एंड ये जो 1 2 3 4 5 है ये हॉप्स हैं।
यही है हॉप्स जो पैकेट एक राउटर से दूसरे
राउटर जा रहा है। तो कितने हॉप्स में ये
पहुंच रहा है? तो नाइंथ हॉप में ये फिर से
Google के पास पहुंच जा रही है। सेम मैं
IP वर्जन 4 की बात करूं तो पहला जो
रिक्वेस्ट है ये देखिए ये मेरे राउटर से
हो के निकल रही है। मेरे राउटर कीप है ये
19268.1.1
ये मेरे राउटर की IP है क्योंकि मैं
Airtel का Fiverr यूज़ कर रहा हूं। तो यहां
पे Airtel का 1926.1.1
गेटवे आईपी होता है। इफ यू डोंट नो लेट मी
शो यू ताकि आपको यकीन हो जाए 192 करूंगा
तो ये जो गेटवे पैनल है वो Airtel का ब्रड
का ओपन हो जाएगा। तो ये मेरी आईपी है।
गेटवे आईपी है। राइट? तो यहां पे अब पहली
रिक्वेस्ट देखो इसको विजुअलाइज करोगे तो
बड़ा मजा आएगा कि सोचो रिक्वेस्ट जा रही
है। यहां लाइव आपको दिख रहा है कि यह
रिक्वेस्ट कहां से जा रही है। पहले मेरे
नेटवर्क से पहले मेरे ही राउटर से तो जा
रही है।
थैंक यू। थैंक यू अशद। हां बाइक बहुत मस्त
है। थैंक यू। तो यहां से आईपी से पहले
मेरी आईपी से गई। दूसरा राउटर यहां पे
उसकी आईपी कुछ ये है। 12276 127 तीसरी
राउटर ये चौथी पांचवी। अब इस वाले केस में
जब वर्जन 4 के थ्रू हमने करा तो यहां पे
कोई भी एस्टेरिस्टिक मार्क नहीं है। सारे
राउटर बढ़िया से काम कर रहे थे आराम से।
एंड सबका टाइमिंग जो है वो ऑलमोस्ट नॉर्मल
था। लेकिन ऊपर वाले में क्या हुआ कि सब एक
तो यहां पे इशूज़ आए। बाकी टाइमिंग्स तो
ठीक है। बट यहां जो फोर्थ हॉप है इसमें जो
दूसरा पैकेट है उसको 21 मिलीसेकंड का टाइम
लगा। यानी कुछ ना कुछ इशू हुआ है। कुछ ना
कुछ प्रॉब्लम हुआ है। तो ये एक तरह का
ट्रबल शूटिंग में भी हेल्प करता है। ये जो
कमांड होता है आपका कि पैकेट को किसी तरह
का कोई ट्रबल हो रहा है। किसी तरह का कोई
इशू आ रहा है। तो ट्रबल शूटिंग में भी
हेल्प करता है आपकी ये ट्रेस रूट कमांड के
थ्रू। कि कोई एक वेबसाइट तक पहुंचने में
किस तरह की दिक्कतें आ सकती हैं। किन-किन
पर्टिकुलर हॉप पे राउटर्स पे किस तरह की
पैकेट्स को दिक्कत आ सकती है या पैकेट
ड्रॉप हो रहा है या डिस्कार्ड हो जा रहा
है तो वो भी आपको पता चल जाता है। ठीक है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब देखो
ये तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हो गई। ये
तो आपने देख लिया। अब मैं आपको यहां पे
दिखाता हूं एक और एग्जांपल जिसमें मैं
irसीटीc का एग्जांपल लूंगा। यहां पे मैंने
Google को किया। अब मैं यहां पे करूंगा
iआरसीटीc.co.in
अब यहां पे फायरवल काम करता है iआरसीटीc
के केस में। तो अब देखो iआरसीटीc के केस
में क्या होता है? पहला वाला तो मेरे
राउटर का है तो जाना ही जाना है। वो तो
होना ही होना है क्योंकि मेरे राउटर से तो
निकलेगा ही रिक्वेस्ट। दूसरा राउटर भी
यहां पे आ चुका है। यह भी सक्सेसफुली काम
कर रहा है। तीसरा भी काम कर रहा है। वाह
क्या बात है यार। चौथा भी काम कर रहा है
क्या? देखते हैं। लेट्स सी। यस। पांचवा
देखते हैं।
देखते जाइए यहां पे।
इट्स वर्किंग।
हां, Windows में टोटल मैक्सिमम हॉप 30
हॉप्स यह ट्राई करेगा। Windows के केस में
ये एक लिमिट है कि बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट क्या करता
है ये? आप इसको चेंज कर सकते हैं 30 हॉप
को कमांड लगा के एच एंड यहां पे 30 हॉब्स
मतलब कि ये 30 बार मैक्सिमम ट्राई करेगा
सर्वर तक पहुंचने का। जो आपने रिक्वेस्ट
ट्रेस रूट सर्वर की रूट को ट्रेस करने के
लिए डाली हुई है। ये 30 हॉप्स तक ट्राई
करेगा। अगर 30 हॉप्स तक पहुंच इसको मिल
गया तब तो ठीक है आपको दे देगा लेकिन अगर
नहीं मिला तो वहां पे एंड हो जाएगा। ये ये
जो रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है वो एंड हो जाएगी।
अभी मैं आपको दिखाऊंगा कि ये इसका मतलब
क्या है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
लेट्स सी
लेट्स सी गाइस।
तीनों पैकेट से कौन सा पैकेट है सर? पैकेट
को आपको नहीं समझना है कि कौन सा है। उसकी
उसके लिए आप बेफिक्र रहिए। वह आपको वह
आपकी रिस्पांसिबिलिटी नहीं है। वह अभी
फिलहाल के लिए उस उसकी कोई आपकी ज़रूरत
नहीं है। ठीक है? मजा आ रहा है क्लास में?
अभी देखो iआरसीटीc के साथ में क्या गेम चल
रहा है। Google में तो आराम से मिल गया सब
कुछ आराम से। राइट?
हां। 30 बार अभी तो 12वां हॉप चल रहा है
ना। 12थ 12थ चल रहा है। इट्स 12थ 30
टाइम्स लगभग ट्राई करेगा यह कि इसको कुछ
अगर मिल जाए पॉजिटिव कुछ ट्रेस हो जाए।
देखो सब में रिक्वेस्ट टाइम आउट्स
एस्टेरिस एस्टेरिक रिक्वेस्ट मतलब जो हम
पिंग पैकेट भेज रहे हैं ना इसको ट्रेस
करने के लिए। हम जो रिक्वेस्ट भेज वो
पहुंच ही नहीं पा रही है उसके राउटर्स तक
जो राउटर शुरू के छह राउटर्स तक तो बढ़िया
से चला सब कुछ रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है। उसके
बाद इन्होंने फायर वॉल या किसी तरह का
रिस्ट्रिक्शन या ब्लॉकेज लगा रखा है
आईआरसीटीसी वालों ने। वहां तक पहुंच ही
नहीं पा रही है। देखो
आईआरसीटीc चल रही है। आईआरसीटीc चल रही
है। ऐसा नहीं है कि ICTC नहीं चल रही है।
यह रिक्वेस्ट टाइम आउट यहां पे ट्रेस रूट
में अगर आ रहा है। इसका मतलब यह नहीं कि
वेबसाइट नहीं चल रही है। वेबसाइट बिल्कुल
अच्छे से चल रही होगी। यहां पिंग में या
ट्रेस रूट कमांड में
दोनों में यही चीज एक खासियत है कि जब
पिंग कर रहे हो तो ऐसा भी हो सकता है कि
वेबसाइट वो चल रही होगी बट पिंग का आपको
रिक्वेस्ट टाइम आउट या कुछ भी रिस्पांस
पॉजिटिव रिस्पांस नहीं आएगा रिप्लाई नहीं
आएगा यह ऐसा इसलिए भी होता है कि उस
पर्टिकुलर राउटर या सर्वर पे पिंग पैकेट्स
को डिटेक्ट करा जा रहा है आईसीएमपी
पैकेट्स को और उसको ब्लॉक कर दिया जा रहा
है ड्रॉप कर दिया जा रहा है मतलब उसका
जवाब बोला जा अरे हट मैं तुम्हें कोई जवाब
नहीं दूंगा। तुम सिक्योरिटी थ्रेट हो मेरे
लिए। तुम पता नहीं पिंग करके क्या करना
चाहते होगे। तो ये एक सिक्योरिटी मेजर है।
इसका मतलब यह नहीं है कि वेबसाइट नहीं चल
रही होगी या चल रही हो। ऐसा कुछ नहीं।
वेबसाइट चल भी सकती है एंड हो सकता है
नहीं भी चल रही हो। राइट?
देखो 20वां रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे आपके सामने
दिख रहा है। इट्स द
20थ रिक्वेस्ट। 20 21 आ गई। मजा आ रहा है
ना?
हां जी। हां जी। हो जाएगी फोर स्कल्प।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम
24 25
देखना 25th पे ये चल रहा है। यहां पे लिखा
है ना मैक्सिमम ऑफ़ 30 हॉप्स तो यह 30 बार
से ज्यादा ट्राई करेगा ही नहीं करेगा।
नहीं करेगा। यह इसकी हिम्मत नहीं है 30
बार से ज्यादा ही ट्राई कर ले। देखना तुम
यह मैं इसको मैं इसको हुकुम दे चुका हूं
कि 30 बार से ज्यादा ट्राई नहीं करना है
क्योंकि यहां 30 लिखा हुआ है। देखो 26वां
अभी कर रहा है। 27वां कर रहा है। देखना 30
से ऊपर अगर 31 हुआ तो मैं यहां जितने
व्यूअर्स हैं उन सबको एक-एक साल का ट्राई
हैक का वाउचर दूंगा। एकदम फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट।
जितने भी व्यूअर्स हैं 65 व्यूअर्स सबको।
अगर यह 31वां रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे आ चुका तो
आ गया तो मैं इसकी गारंटी देता हूं। 30 30
तक ही रहेगा यह
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
30 इसके बाद अगर एक और रिक्वेस्ट आई तो
सबको ट्राई हैक मी अपनी बातों पर रहूंगा
मैं देख लेना और अगर नहीं आई तो नहीं
मिलेगा
देखा खत्म [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो 30 रिक्वेस्ट में ट्रेस कंप्लीट हो
चुकी है। राइट? 31 आपको तो दिखी नहीं कहीं
पे है ना? 31 31 नहीं दिखी। राइट? तो 30
रिक्वेस्ट में यहां पे क्योंकि यहां पे
मैक्सिमम 30 होप्स लिखा हुआ था। तो यहां
पे ट्रेस कंप्लीट हो चुका है। लास्ट में
रिक्वेस्ट टाइम आउट हो चुका है। अब इसने
बोला कि भैया अब मेरे से नहीं होगा। ये
बेचारा कुछ कोई भी राउटर कुछ भी रिस्पांस
आ नहीं रहा है। तो अब ना होगा। अब हम हमसे
नहीं हो पाएगा। तो ये अब iआरसीटीc में जो
ये हॉप्स आपको ये खाली दिख रहे हैं। यानी
कि यहां पे जो राउटर्स लगे हुए हैं जिनके
थ्रू रिक्वेस्ट जा रही थी जानी थी वो
रिसोंड नहीं कर रहे हैं हमारे रिक्वेस्ट
का हमारे मतलब इसका मतलब सिंपल सा है कि
हम किसी के घर जा रहे हैं उसका दरवाजा
खटखटा रहे हैं। कोई है कोई है उधर से कोई
रिस्पांस आ ही नहीं रहा। तो आप क्या
समझेंगे? सिंपल सा फंडा है कि आप दरवाजा
खटखटा रहे हैं किसी का और कोई रिस्पांस ही
नहीं आ रहा उधर से तो आप यह थोड़ी ना समझ
लें कि घर में कोई नहीं है। ऐसा भी तो हो
सकता है कि घर में सब लोग हो जानबूझ के वो
रिसोंड ना कर रहे हो। उनको एक सिक्योरिटी
थ्रेट लग रही है। उनको लग रहा हो कि कोई
आके उनको मार मूड़ देगा। आज का जमाना बहुत
खराब है। ऐसा भी तो हो सकता है। सिमिलर
गोज़ टू दीज़ राउटर्स। कि इनको हम जा के
खटखटा तो रहे हैं। बट किसी सिक्योरिटी
इश्यूज की वजह से या किसी ना किसी या हो
सकता है कि घर में के जो लोग हैं वो किसी
प्रॉब्लम में है या कोई सुन ही नहीं पा
रहा। कुछ भी हो सकता है ना एनीथिंग सबके
कान बहरे हो गए हैं वो भी हो सकता है मैल
फंक्शनिंग हो गई हो तो द सिमिलर थिंग्स आर
हियर रियल लाइफ से थोड़ा सा रिलेट कर दिया
आपको याद रहेगा ठीक है समझ में आ गया
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
गॉट इट चलिए आई होप कि आपको यह चीजें
ट्रेस रूट वाली सभी को समझ में आ गई सभी
को समझ में आ गई ट्रेस रूट वाली चीजें
एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड
एवरीवन
एवरीवन गॉट इट
ओके गुड गुड गुड वेरी गुड चलिए सो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] लेट्स क्लियर
इट लेट्स एग्जिट फ्रॉम दिस लेट्स गो बैक
टू आवर स्लाइड ओके तो अब टीटीएल के केस
में होता क्या है एक्जेक्टली देखो देखो
ड्रॉप क्यों होती है पैकेट्स। पैकेट्स
क्यों ड्रॉप होती है? जैसे आप कोई
रिक्वेस्ट भेज रहे हो तो पैकेट को ड्रॉप
कर दिया जाता है। रिक्वेस्ट वहीं पे एंड
कर दी जाती है। वो किस सिनेरियो में क्यों
होता है? इसका भी रीज़न मैं आपको बताता
हूं। देखो क्या होता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
क्लाइंट रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है सर्वर तक।
डेस्टिनेशन ये सर्वर है आपका। बीच में
राउटर्स होते हैं। मल्टीपल राउटर्स होते
हैं। राइट? देयर कैन बी मल्टीपल राउटर्स।
ये तीन दिखा रहे हैं यहां पे। यहां पे
ज्यादा राउटर्स भी हो सकते हैं।
तीन से भी ज्यादा हो सकते हैं। बट
एग्जांपल के लिए मैं आपको यहां पर बता रहा
हूं। अब पहले जब क्लाइंट ने रिक्वेस्ट
भेजी उस समय मान लो टीटीएल वैल्यू वन थी।
वन थी। तो ये एक रूल है कि जब भी टीटीएल
वैल्यू जो भी टीटीएल वैल्यू पहले राउटर के
पास जाती है या सब्सक्वेंट राउटर्स के पास
जाती है दूसरे तीसरे हर राउटर उस टीटीएल
वैल्यू से वन माइनस करके ही आगे फॉरवर्ड
करता है। बट अगर किसी पॉइंट पर वह वैल्यू
जीरो हो जाती है तो उस पैकेट को उस आईपी
पैकेट को डेटा पैकेट को वहीं पे ड्रॉप कर
देना होता है। वहीं पे डिस्कार्ड कर देना
है। मतलब वो अब रिक्वेस्ट इनवैलिड हो गई।
वो रिक्वेस्ट को वहीं पे ड्रॉप मारो। एज
सिंपल एज दैट। समझ में आ गया? एज सिंपल एज
दैट। तो यहां अगर डीटीएल वैल्यू वन जाती
है तो ये तो पहले राउटर पे ही 1 - 1 हो जा
रही है ना भाई। यह तो पहले राउटर पर ही 1
- 1 0 हो जा रहा है। तो यहीं पर यह
कनेक्शन ड्रॉप हो जाएगी। यह देखो कनेक्शन
क्लोज।
सिंपल आगे की सिंपल मतलब यहीं पे कनेक्शन
क्या हो जा रहा है? क्लोज हो जा रहा है।
कनेक्शन ड्रॉप कर दी जा रही है। खत्म
कहानी। अब जब कनेक्शन ड्रॉप कर दी जाएगी
तो यह मैसेज हमारे क्लाइंट को पहुंचा दिया
जाता है वापस। आईसीएमपी प्रोटोकॉल के थ्रू
यह जो राउटर है यह बोलेगा अरे तुम्हारा जो
था ना भाई वह गया
इसको मैं
यहां पे किसके थ्रू
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] आईसीएमपी के
थ्रू यह मैसेज पहुंचा दिया जाता है
क्लाइंट को कि भैया जीरो हो गई है
टीडीटीएल तुम्हारे किसी काम का नहीं है अब
निकलो तुम अब यह फिर से अब क्लाइंट क्या
बोलता है क्लाइंट बहुत चालाक है। क्लाइंट
चालाक है। क्लाइंट बोलता है अच्छा बेटा
ज़ीरो कर दिया। ठीक है। चलो मैं एक टीएल
बढ़ा के भेजता हूं तुम्हें। अब जो मैंने
पहले वन भेजा था टीटीएल अब मैं टू
भेजूंगा। देखते हैं फिर अब टू टीटीएल
जाएगी पहले राउटर के पास। तो पहला बोलेगा
अच्छा टू भेजा है। तो 2 - 1 2 - 1 तो फिर
भी वन बचा। ज़ीरो तो नहीं हुआ। अब वन बचा
तो ये आगे इसको फॉरवर्ड कर देगा दूसरे
वाले राउटर को। अब दूसरा राउटर भी 1 - 1
कर देगा। अब यहां पर डिस्कार्ड हो जाएगा
और यह जो है भेज देगा इंफॉर्मेशन फिर से
क्लाइंट को कि भैया आईसीएमपी के थ्रू कि
भैया जीरो हो गया नहीं पहुंच पाएगा आगे तक
नहीं जा पाएगा होस्ट तक नहीं जा पाएगा अब
क्लाइंट दुखी बेचारा यहां तो पहुंचा नहीं
यहां भी नहीं पहुंचा अब यह बोलेगा अच्छा
बेटा कोई बात नहीं अब मैं जो है यह तो
यहां वन भेजा था यहां क्या भेजा था वन
प्लस
वन
अब यहां पे मैं भेजूंगा 2 + 1 जो मैंने
पहले टू भेजा था उसमें वन ऐड करके
भेजूंगा। तो अब भेज रहा है यह थ्री तीन
वैल्यू तो पहले राउटर पे 3 - 1 पास हो
गया। 3 - 1 पास हो गया। यहां टू गई। अब
इसने क्या किया? 2 - 1 कर दिया। यहां से
भी पास हो गया। अब इस वाले राउटर पे गई।
अब यहां वन गया तो यह 1 - 1 हुआ। और जैसे
ही 1 - 1 हुआ ज़ीरो हो गया। यहां पे फिर से
फेल हो गया। और यह फिर से इनेशन इसको देता
है कि भैया आईसीएमपी के थ्रू कि भैया ना
हो पाएगा।
तुम्हारे बस की बात नहीं है। चलो हटाओ।
क्लाइंट बोला मैं क्लाइंट हूं। मैं थोड़ी
ना मेरे को तो हाथ आगे करके कटोरा ले भीख
मांगना है। रिक्वेस्ट करना है सर्वर से।
भैया दे दो मुझे रिस्पांस। तो मैं
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो हार नहीं
मानने वाला। अब क्या करेगा? यह जो क्लाइंट
है अब यहां पे 3 + 1 करके चार को भेजेगा।
ले भाई अब तू जा। चार कुछ करके आ। पहला
राउटर 4 - 1 थ्री बचा। चला गया। आगे 3 - 1
टू बचा। आगे चला गया। 2 - 1 वन बचा आगे
चला गया। वन बचा एंड ये सर्वर को डिलीवर
हो गया। यानी कि यह पैकेट जो है वो
डेस्टिनेशन तक पहुंच गई भैया हमारी। यह
पैकेट कहां तक पहुंच गई? डेस्टिनेशन तक
पहुंच गई हमारी। और यहां पे हमारा जो
पैकेट है वो फाइनली डिलीवर हो चुका है।
किसी भी तरीके से यह डिस्कार्ड नहीं हुआ
है। एंड नाउ दिस पर्टिकुलर थिंग मेक्स
सेंस कि यह टीटीएल कुछ इस तरीके से काम
करती है। अगर यही चीज ना हो तो एक पैकेट
एक बार जो क्लाइंट से निकली है वो ट्रेवल
करती रह जाएगी। करती रहेगी। वो कभी खत्म
ही नहीं होगी क्योंकि उसको माइनस नहीं हो
रहा वो पॉइंट और ज़ीरो भी नहीं होगा कभी
जिंदगी में तो वो हमेशा ट्रैवल करती रह
जाएगी लाइफ टाइम एंड पूरे वर्ल्ड के
नेटवर्क में कंजेशन आ जाएगा क्योंकि
टीटीएल का कंसेप्ट अगर नहीं रहेगा तो
टीटीएल के बिना किसी तरह का कम्युनिकेशन
पॉसिबल ही नहीं है। पहली बात तो टाइम टू
लिव के बिना कोई भी कम्युनिकेशन रिक्वेस्ट
रिस्पांस पॉसिबल नहीं है दो डिवाइसेस के
बीच में। सो इट्स अ वेरी वेरी इंपॉर्टेंट
कंसेप्ट जो कि एग्ज़िस्ट करना चाहिए।
ये तो समझ में आ गया होगा आपको राइट इट्स
अ नॉर्मल सीन तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ये इस तरीके
से पूरी टीएल अब ये टीएल वैल्यू देखो आप
इसको दिल पे मत ले लेना कि सर 1 2 3 4
डिटेल वैल्यू फाइव भी हो सकती कुछ भी हो
सकता है दिस टीl वैल्यू कैन बी एनीथिंग
डिपेंडिंग ऑन द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एंड ये
लेकिन -1 जरूर होएगी सब्सक्वेंट राउटर्स
पे जो भी क्सक्यूटिव राउटर्स होंगे आगे
वाला वो एक-एक माइनस करके ही भेजेगा
बस इतना हमें जानना है इसके बारे में गॉट
इट समझ में आ चुका इतना क्लियर है भाई
बताइए मुझे क्लियर है एकदम क्लियर है थैंक
यू नाम देखो फेक फर्स्ट रखा है बोले भी तो
क्या बोले इंसान थैंक यू फेक फर्स्ट
अ ओके एवरीथिंग इज क्लियर राइट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब आगे की तरफ
चलते हैं इसी को मैं थोड़ा सा
टेक्स्ट में समझाता हूं हाउ डिटेल वर्क्स
मैंने हालांकि सब कुछ आपको डिटेल में
बताया व्हेन अ पैकेट ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन इज
क्रिएटेड एंड सेंट टू अक्रॉस द इंटरनेट
देयर इज़ अ रिस्क दैट इट विल कंटिन्यू टू
पास फ्रॉम राउटर टू राउटर इनफाइनाइटली
राउटर से राउटर वो पास होता रहेगा मैंने
जैसे बताया यह रिस्क होता है टू मिटिगेट
दिस पॉसिबिलिटी पैकेट्स आर डिज़ विद एन
एक्सपायरेशन कॉल्ड अ टाइम टू लिव और हॉप
लिमिट इसी चीज से बचने के लिए पैकेट्स का
एक एक्सपायरी क्रिएट किया गया एक्सपायरी
ठीक है अब मान लो कोई खाना हो कोई मेडिसिन
हो बिना एक्सपायरी का हो वो चलता ही रह
जाएगा यार वो तो जिंदगी भर वो कभी खत्म ही
नहीं होगी एक्स एक्स डिटेक्ट वो खत्म वो
ही नहीं होगी उसी तरीके से पैकेट्स का भी
एक्सपायरी टाइम टाइम टू लिफ्ट के थ्रू या
हॉप लिमिट भी इसको बोलते हैं के थ्रू
बनाया गया कि भैया तुम जो है वो कुछ इतने
टाइम तक ही ट्रैवल करना ठीक है उसके बाद
मत करना दिक्कत हो जाएगी नहीं तो बाकी भी
लोगों को मौका दो यार पैकेट्स टीटीएल कैन
आल्सो बी यूज़फुल इन डिटरमाइनिंग हाउ
लॉन्ग अ पैकेट हैज बीन इन सर्कुलेशन
एंड अलव द सेंडर टू रिसीव इंफॉर्मेशन
अबाउट अ पैकेट्स पाथ थ्रू द इंटरनेट।
ट्रेस रूट। ट्रेस रूट में हम यही पता
लगाते हैं कि भैया एक जो पैकेट है वो
कितने टाइम ले रही है जाके आने में। और यह
भी पता चलता है पैकेट के बारे में कि यह
कितने टाइम से सर्कुलेट हो रहा है। इससे
भी आईडिया लगता है ये एक पैकेट। तो यह
बताता है डिटेल। ईच पैकेट हैज़ अ प्लेस
वेयर इट स्टोर्स अ न्यूममेरिक वैल्यू
डिटरमाइनिंग हाउ मच लगर इट शुड कंटिन्यू
टू मूव थ्रू द नेटवर्क। ठीक है? एव्री
टाइम अ राउटर रिसीव अ पैकेट इट
सब्सट्रैक्ट वन फ्रॉम द टीएल काउंट एंड
देन पाससेस ऑन टू द नेक्स्ट लोकेशन इन द
नेटवर्क। एट एनी पॉइंट टीएल काउंट इज़
इक्वल टू ज़ीरो आफ्टर द सब्सट्रैक्शन। द
राउटर विल डि डिकार द पैकेट एंड सेंड एन
आईसीएमपी मैसेज बैक टू द ओरिजिन होस्ट। जो
मैंने वहां प्रैक्टिकल आपको सामने
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन के थ्रू बताया। वही यहां पे
टेक्स्ट में है। अगर यही चीज आप इंटरनेट
पे टेक्स्ट के थ्रू सिर्फ पढ़ते हैं। एक
दो अगर इमेज भी ओनली देख लेते हैं। आपको
समझ में नहीं आएगा। आप कंफ्यूज हो जाएंगे
कि भैया ये क्या है? वन माइनस करके ज़ीरो
हो रहा है ये। लेकिन यहां जब मैंने आपको
ये चीजें समझा दी विजुअलाइज करा के समझाया
तो आपको ये चीज क्लेरिटी के साथ समझ में आ
चुकी होगी। आपके दिमाग में वो सेट कर
जाएगा। तो मेन यहां पे मुद्दा यही है कि
आप साइबर सिक्योरिटी हो गई या एस मतलब
उसका जो भी डोमेन है या एसओसी हो गया
डिजिटल फर्स्ट ये सब डोमेनस में जो भी
चीजें आप सीखते हैं उसको आप एक
स्ट्रक्चरर्ड वे में जब सीखेंगे ना एक
प्रॉपर कांसेप्ट्स के साथ समझते-समझते तो
आपको समझ में आएगा। अदरवाइज बहुत मुश्किल
है। कभी कोई कांसेप्ट बहुत आपको मुश्किल
लगेगा। बहुत लगेगा। टफ लगेगा। अरे यार
क्या हो रहा है ये? बट होते बहुत इजी होते
हैं जनरली। अगर उनको समझा जाए तो इस तरीके
से डिटेल वर्क करते हैं। अब यहां पे मैंने
पहले ही बता रखा है पिंग एंड ट्रेस रूट या
ट्रेस आर्टिकम दोनों टीटीएल को यूटिलाइज
करते हैं। बस टीटीएल को यूटिलाइज करते
हैं। बस इतना समझ लीजिए। सेम चीज़ है जो
मैंने बता दी थी वही चीज़ है। ठीक है? आपको
ये चीज़ समझ में आ गई होगी। आई होप सो।
राइट? टीएल क्लियर है आपका। अब यहां पे
हमने पैकेट्स के बारे में जाना। हमने
टीटीएल के बारे में जाना। अब हम यहां पे
जानेंगे थ्री वे हैंडशक के बारे में। एंड
थ्री वे हैंडशक इज अ वेरी यूनिक एंड वेरी
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक मेरे हिसाब से। एंड
इसके बिना कोई कम्युनिकेशन नहीं होती है।
जैसे टीटीएल के बिना कम्युनिकेशन पॉसिबल
नहीं है। इसके बिना तो कम्युनिकेशन
स्टार्ट ही नहीं होगी। पहली बात है। राइट?
तो इसको भी हम समझते हैं। छोटी सी टॉपिक
है। देख लीजिए। 8:30 तक आई थिंक आप लोगों
का कंप्लीट हो जाएगा। तो आई होप कि आप सभी
तब तक बने रहेंगे। राइट
चैट में कुछ लोग बहुत मस्ती करते हैं। चैट
में रहते इधर ध्यान क्यों नहीं रहा था
आपका?
आई एम वर्किंग इन फार्मचर।
देखो प्रैक्टिकल वाजू पे हो या कोई और टूल
पे हो उससे फर्क नहीं पड़ता है। ऑलमोस्ट
जितने भी टूल्स हैं ना उनका वे वर्किंग वे
जो है वो ऑलमोस्ट सेम ही होता है यार।
कुछ-कुछ चीजें बस चेंज हो जाती हैं। उसका
मतलब एक एग्जीक्यूशन का थोड़ा तरीका अलग
हो जाता है। एक एंड रिजल्ट क्या हमें अचीव
करना है उस टूल से वो तो सबका सेम ही होता
है। बस इतना ही मुझे पता है। अब डीडीओएस
अटैक के मल्टीपल टूल्स हैं। एंड रिजल्ट
एंड जो हमारा गोल है वो क्या होता है कि
एक एक डॉस अटैक एक डिस्ट्रीब्यूटेड डिनाइल
ऑफ़ सर्विस अटैक करना। सब टूल्स अलग-अलग
होते हैं। तरीका अलग होता है। कमांड्स अलग
हो गए हैं। डिलीवरी मेथड अलग हो गया उनका।
लेकिन होता तो वही चीज है। तो वो चीज मेरे
को लगता है सीखना जरूरी है आपको। खैर उस
पे हम आएंगे। ठीक है? हम उस पे आएंगे। अब
आते हैं यहां पे थ्री वे हैंडशक के ऊपर
में। अब थ्री वे हैंडशक को मैं यहां पे
समझाऊंगा। उससे पहले मैं यहां पे समझाना
चाहता हूं आपको। ठीक है? थ्री वे हैंडशक
क्या एक्सैक्टली होता है? देखो एक होती है
क्लाइंट। एक होता है सर्वर। यहां मैं समझा
दूंगा ना तो वहां मैं बहुत ईज़ली और बहुत
जल्दी हो जाएगा वहां पे। देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम यहां समझ रहे हैं टीसीपी थ्री वे
हैंडशक टीसीपी
थ्री वे हैंडशक
अब
यहां पे क्लाइंट यूजुअली मैंने आपको क्या
बताया था कि क्लाइंट रिक्वेस्ट करता है
सर्वर रिसोंड करता है बट एक्चुअली क्या
होता है वह मैं आपको बताता हूं
सबसे पहले क्लाइंट रिक्वेस्ट करता है।
इस रिक्वेस्ट को इस रिक्वेस्ट को सर्वर जो
है रिसोंड करता है
और उसके बाद क्लाइंट फिर से
एक रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है या यूं बोलिए कि
एकनॉलेज करता है उस रिस्पांस को ए सी के
एकनॉलेज करता है उस रिस्पांस को। मतलब
क्या हुआ? इसका मतलब सीधा-सीधा समझिए कि
अगर आप किसी के पास हेल्प लेने के लिए
जाते हैं, किसी भी तरह का कोई हेल्प लेने
जाते हैं। राइट? इफ यू वांट सम हेल्प
फ्रॉम समवन।
तो जब आप हेल्प लेने जाते हैं तो उस केस
में क्या होता है?
उस केस में आपको अगर हेल्प मिल जाती है तो
आप उसको थैंक यू तो बोलते हैं ना। या फिर
ऐसे ही अगर मान लो आप अपने दोस्त से कोई
पैसे मांग रहे हैं। भाई यह ₹10 देना यार
कुछ बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट काम है। बहुत जरूरी
है। आपके दोस्त ने बोला कि ₹10 है तो नहीं
बट अरेंज करके देता हूं मैं। वो अरेंज
करके आपको ₹10 दे देता है। तो आप ऐसे ही
₹10 लेके निकल जाओगे। अरे यार ज्यादा मिल
गया। या उसको बोलोगे थैंक यू भाई। थैंक यू
दोस्त या भाई बहुत अच्छा लगा। तुमने ₹10
दे दिए काम पे। काम आ गए तुम। इससे मेरी
लाइफ बन जाएगी। यह तुम कुछ ना कुछ तो
एकनॉलेज करोगे। कुछ ना कुछ तो कंफर्मेशन
करोगे। राइट? तो सेम चीज जो है यहां पे
क्लाइंट एंड सर्वर के बीच में होती है। बस
इसी को हम क्योंकि ये तीन स्टेप्स में
होता है। इसको हम थ्री वे बोलते हैं।
हैंडशेक। हैंडशेक का मतलब है हाथ मिला
लिया भैया कि अब भैया हो चुकी है हम दो
हमारी बात हो चुकी है। हमारी कनेक्शन
इस्टैब्लिश हो चुकी है। अब हम कम्युनिकेशन
स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? ये चीज़ होती
है। हां ये TCP प्रोटोकॉल की बात हो रही
है यहां पे। दिस इज़ द ट्रीसीपी ये TCP का
होता है। TCP में होता है। राइट? TCP में
क्योंकि यूडीपी जो है ना वो थोड़ा सा फालतू
प्रोटोकॉल है। कनेक्शन प्रोटोकॉल होता है।
उसको कोई मतलब नहीं है यार। किसी भी तरह
की एरर रिपोर्टिंग और किसी भी तरह की इशूज़
से बिंदास चलता है वो। तो ये टीसीपी
हैंडशक है। राइट?
ठीक है? अब देखिए अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां जो
रिक्वेस्ट पहली जा रही है, इस रिक्वेस्ट
को हम यहां पे बोलते हैं सन।
यहां पे यह सन रिक्वेस्ट होती है। इसको हम
बोलते हैं सन रिक्वेस्ट। एस आई एस वाई एन
सन। सिंक्रोनाइजेशन
इसका फुल फॉर्म होता है। सर्वर जब रिसोंड
करता है तो इसमें यह दो या सिन पैकेट बोल
लीजिए या सिन फ्लैग बोल लीजिए। दो फ्लैग्स
होते हैं। सिन
स्लश एसी के जो सन रिक्वेस्ट गई थी उसी का
सन रिस्पांस और उसको एकनॉलेज करना कि हां
भैया मुझे आपका रिक्वेस्ट मिल चुका है। अब
ये लो रिस्पांस दैट्स इट। और तीसरा जो
होता है इसमें आपका होता है एसी के फ्लैग
या एसी के
जो पैकेट है वो होती है आपकी ठीक है ये
तीन चीजें होती है तो यहां पे पहले नंबर
पे सन दूसरे नंबर पे सीन एसी के तीसरे
नंबर पे फिर एसी के एकनॉलेजमेंट होती है
पहली जो रिक्वेस्ट गई है उसको सन फ्लैग के
थ्रू होता है वो सन फ्लैग समझ लीजिए वो
वहां पे आ रही है सन रिक्वेस्ट जा रही सन
रिक्वेस्ट है वहां पे दूसरे रिस्पांस में
सीन एसी के एज अ रिस्पांस एंड तीसरे
कंफर्मेशन में एसीके आ रहा है। तो यहां पे
तीन चीजें हो रही है। सीन फ्लैग, सीन एसी
के फ्लैग एंड एसी के फ्लैग। अब इन्हीं सन
सीन एसी के एसी के ये जो है ना सन और
एसीके इनको हम टीसीपी फ्लैग्स बोलते हैं
जो एक कनेक्शन के बारे में बताती है। इनको
हम टीसी पे टीसी टीसीपी फ्लैग्स बोलते
हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इसको हम क्या बोलते हैं? इसको हम टीसीपी
फ्लैग्स बोलते हैं। दिस आर नोन एज
फ्लैग्स। अब इसी को हम थोड़ा वहां पे
डिटेल में समझेंगे। चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम अब यहां पे आते हैं। लेट्स गो ऑन द
थ्री वे हैंडशक थिंग। टीसीपी थ्री वे
हैंडशक का। यहां पर एक एक मैं
रिटन में यहां पर मैं आपसे थोड़ा सा बताने
वाला हूं एक कॉन्टेक्स्ट के थ्रू। द
हैंडशक इज अ डेटा शेयरिंग प्रोसेस दैट
इनवॉल्व्स अ बैक एंड फोर्थ कम्युनिकेशन
बिटवीन अ क्लाइंट एग्जांपल है मोबाइल फोन
या स्मार्ट टीवी एंड अ सर्वर। एक क्लाइंट
और सर्वर के बीच में बैक एंड फोर्थ आगे
पीछे जो कम्युनिकेशन होती है उसमें जो
डाटा शेयरिंग प्रोसेस है उसको हम हैंडशक
बोलते हैं। द पर्पस ऑफ़ दिस कम्युनिकेशन इज़
टु एस्टैब्लिश अ सिक्योर एंड रिलायबल
कनेक्शन।
सो दैट द डेटा डेटा में जैसे फाइल्स हो
गई, आपकी इमेजज़ हो गई, वीडियोस हो गई कैन
बी ट्रांसफरर्ड एफिशिएंटली बिटवीन द
सिस्टम्स। मतलब दो सिस्टम्स के बीच दो या
दो से ज्यादा सिस्टम्स के बीच डेटा
एफिशिएंटली ट्रांसफर हो सके। कम्युनिकेशन
एफिशिएंटली हो सके। एक रिलायबल सिक्योर
कम्युनिकेशन एस्टैब्लिश हो सके। यही पर्पस
है इस थ्री वे हैंडशक का।
यही यही है। बस मेन यही इसका
पर्पस होता है।
एक सिक्योर एंड रिलायबल कनेक्शन
इस्टैब्लिश हो सके। दैट्स इट। यह टीसीp 3
एंड से का पर्पस है। अब देखिए अब कुछ इस
तरीके से रिक्वेस्ट थोड़ा सा और टेक्निकल
जाके मैं आपको बताऊंगा और थोड़ा सा
टेक्निकल जाके कुछ इस तरीके से यह
रिक्वेस्ट ट्रैवल कर रही होती है। क्या
होता है? क्लाइंट होता है आपका सर्वर होता
है। क्लाइंट एक सन रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है।
क्लाइंट एक सन रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है। यह टॉप
टू बॉटम हम आएंगे। सीन में सिंक्रोनाइजेशन
उसको बोलते हैं। तो उसमें एक सीक्वेंस
नंबर होता है। क्योंकि यह जो रिक्वेस्ट
होती है ना वो एक सीक्वेंस में जाती है।
ठीक है? हर रिक्वेस्ट एक सीक्वेंस में
जाता है। अगर रिक्वेस्ट सीक्वेंस में नहीं
जाएंगी फिर तो सीक्वेंस रिक्वेस्ट
सीक्वेंस कम्युनिकेशन नहीं होगी। फिर कैसे
होगा? अगर कोई मान लो कि मैं कोई एक
रिक्वेस्ट भेज रहा हूं किसी सर्वर को
Facebook को। ठीक है? और मेरे पास एक और
रिक्वेस्ट Facebook को सेम पाथ के लिए आ
रही है। तो एक रिक्वेस्ट एक एक क्या होता
है? सीक्वेंस में जाती है कि भैया इसका
पहले आया है तो इसको पहले दे दो। मतलब
पहले अगर पहुंचे हैं आपके द्वार पे कोई है
तो आप उनको पहले सर्व करेंगे। बाद में
दूसरा कोई आ रहा है तो यहां पे दूसरे को
सर्व किया जाएगा। तो एक सीक्वेंस में एक
लाइन बना के क्यू बना के यहां पे चला जा
रहा है। तो उस लाइन का एक लाइन नंबर एक जो
सीक्वेंस है जैसे उसका एक नंबर दे दिया
गया। जैसे अगर आप
थिएटर्स [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वगैरह
में पुराने बहुत पहले जब थिएटर्स में जाते
थे तो सीट नंबर्स और ये सब से नहीं होते
थे। वहां पे एक नंबर आपको दे दिया जाता
था। ये लाइन का नंबर कि हां भैया ये नंबर
पे आया है। आपको जाके लाइन में लग जाइए।
अब उसी सीक्वेंस में लाइन में नंबर नंबर
लाइन में नंबर लगना पड़ता था कि आपका नंबर
पांच है तो आप पांचवें नंबर पे लगेंगे और
पहले नंबर को घुसाएंगे दूसरे तीसरे ऐसे
करके और जो अंदर पहले जाएगा वो सीट लेके
बैठ जाएगा। जिसको सीट मिली मिली नहीं मिली
तो जय श्री राम। तो वो चीज होती थी। तो
सेम चीज यहां पे सीक्वेंस जो भेजा जाता है
उसमें एक सीक्वेंस नंबर असाइन कर दिया
जाता है। लेट्स सपोज़ कि यहां पे एम असाइन
किया। ये सीक्वेंस का नंबर है m इसका एक
फिक्स नंबर एक एक मतलब वैल्यू असाइन कर
दिया है। कुछ भी हो सकता है। इट कैन बी
रैंडम m हो गया। अब क्लाइंट ने सीन
रिक्वेस्ट भेजा। सीन भेजा पैकेट फ्लैग।
सर्वर ने सीन को रिसीव किया एंड सीक्वेंस
नंबर एम इसको रिसीव किया। अब सर्वर जब
रिस्पॉन्ड करेगा तो यहां पे नियम एंड रूल
क्या है? कि ये सीन को तो भेजेगा यहां
सीन। अब यहां पर जो सीक्वेंस यहां पर m
आया था यह एक नया सीक्वेंस जनरेट करेगा
अपना खुद का रिस्पांस का सीक्वेंस तो उसको
एक नंबर दे देगा जैसे इसने दे दिया n अब m
क्लाइंट का एम था इसका एन दे दिया लेकिन
साथ ही में एक एसी के भी भेजेगा
एकनॉलेजमेंट का उस एकनॉलेजमेंट में वो
क्लाइंट वाला जो सीन का जो नंबर था ना
उसमें प्लस वन करके भेज देगा इसलिए करेगा
ताकि उसको यह बता बता सके सर्वर हमारा यह
बता सके क्लाइंट को कि भैया मैं आपके ही
रिक्वेस्ट को फुलफिल कर रहा हूं। आपको भला
नहीं हूं मैं। आपका जो m आया था ना उसमें
वन जोड़ दिया है मैंने। लो ताकि आपको भी
तो पता चले कि हां सर्वर से जो आया है वह
हमारा ही तो आया है। m + 1 है मतलब मेरा
है। मैंने m भेजा था। m + 1 करके इन्होंने
उसको एकनॉलेज करा है। एक्सेप्ट करा है और
अपना एक नया सीक्वेंस को स्टार्ट करा है
कि भैया मैं रिस्पॉन्ड कर रहा हूं इस
सीक्वेंस नंबर से जो कि n है। तो अब जब
क्लाइंट वापस से इसको कंफर्म करेगा कि
भैया मुझे आपका रिस्पांस मिल चुका है तो
उसी एन से करना पड़ेगा। तभी तो सर्वर को
पता चलेगा कि हां क्लाइंट सही रिसोंड कर
रहा है। मतलब क्लाइंट जो है कंफर्मेशन जो
कर रहा है वो सही कर रहा है। क्योंकि यह
तो मेरा ही सीक्वेंस नंबर था एन वाला। तो
क्लाइंट अब क्या करेगा व्हाट वी विल डू कि
यह जो एसी के है क्लाइंट इसको भेजेगा
सर्वर को। बट उसमें क्या करेगा? n + 1 कर
देगा। जो सर्वर से पहले n आया था उसमें n
+ 1 करके इसी के भेज देगा सर्वर को और
एकनॉलेज करेगा कि भैया सर्वर जी मैंने जो
आपसे विनती की थी रिक्वेस्ट करी थी उस
रिक्वेस्ट को आपने फुलफिल करा और वो
रिक्वेस्ट मेरी फुलफिल हो गई इसके लिए मैं
हां जोड़ता हूं आपके और n + 1 करके आपको
कंफर्म करता हूं कि हां आपने मेरी हेल्प
करी भैया दैट्स इट सैट सिंपल एज दैट यह
बहुत ही बेसिक सा एक वर्किंग सिनेरियो है
थ्री वे हैंडसेटिक का इतने सिंपल तरीके से
आपको शायद कोई नहीं बताएगा। मैंने बहुत
सिंपल वे में आपको बताया है। यह बहुत
कॉम्प्लेक्स चीज है। इसके अंदर मल्टीपल
डिफरेंट थिंग्स हैपन। इसके अंदर और बहुत
कुछ होता है। अभी आपको पता नहीं है थ्री
वे हैंडशक के ऊपर में आप 10 क्लासेस भी
करोगे तो जाके कहीं आपको लगेगा कि हां ये
पूरा हुआ। लेकिन अभी मैंने जो आपको बताया
है ये सबसे कोर बेसिक कांसेप्ट्स है जिसके
ऊपर पूरा थ्री वे हैंडशक काम करता है। एंड
यहीं रहेगा हमेशा। इसमें कोई चेंज नहीं हो
सकता है। नेवर एवर। आप कितना भी
कॉम्प्लेक्स टेक्नलिटी घुसा दो बेस स्कोर
आपका उसका सबका हर जगह से यही रहने वाला
है। तो इसको दिमाग में बिठा लीजिएगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है?
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
लाइक ठोक दिया यार सब लोग लाइक नहीं ठोकते
यार। 100 लाइक्स भी नहीं हुए बताओ। चलो
कोई बात नहीं। लाइक ठोक दिया करो। शेयर तो
कर ही दिया करना।
तो अभी समझ में आया आप लोगों को? यहां पे
ये पूरा माजरा समझ में आ गया। बहुत आसान
था। क्लाइंट ने सन रिक्वेस्ट भेजा। एम
नंबर नाम दिया। एम उसको वैल्यू दी। सर्वर
को मिला उसने एम वाली रिक्वेस्ट। अब सर्वर
ने वापस से रिसोंड किया। तो अब उसने एक
नया सीक्वेंस एन किया ताकि क्लाइंट बाद
में एन के थ्रू रिप्लाई कर पाए और एक
एसीके को भेज दिया। एकनॉलेजमेंट कर ली कि
भैया हां ठीक है रिक्वेस्ट मिल चुकी है।
उसमें m + 1 कर दिया इसके पिछले एम को
ताकि कंफर्म कर सके कि हां भैया मैं आपके
उसी रिक्वेस्ट का रिप्लाई कर रहा हूं। और
क्लाइंट को जब रिप्लाई मिला तो देखा कि
अरे भाई वाह एक तो हमारा m + 1 आया तो ठीक
है सर्वर भैया सही है और एक नया सीक्वेंस
नंबर सर्वर भैया ने भेजा है n का तो अब
क्या करना है अब n को n + 1 करके सर्वर
भैया को भेज देना है कि भैया मैंने कंफर्म
मैं कर रहा हूं कि बस सब ठीक है चल रहा है
कम्युनिकेशन स्टार्ट की जाए अब हम दोनों
बात कर सकते हैं हम दोनों ऑथेंटिकेट हो
सके हैंडशेक हो चुका तो ये ऑथेंटिकेट हुए
एक दूसरे से ये क्या हुए ऑथेंटिकेट हुए
मतलब ये एक दूसरे से आप
बात करने लगेंगे। अब कम्युनिकेशन अब
स्टार्ट हो सकती है थ्री वे हैंडशक के
बाद। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
गॉट इट लाइक हो गया। क्या बात है। थैंक यू
वेरी मच। 94 लाइक्स हो गए। अच्छी बात है।
100 भी हो जाएंगे मुझे पता है। तो ये सभी
को समझ में आ गया? ये पूरा ये पूरा माजरा
आपको क्लियर हो गया? पहले मुझे बता दीजिए।
लेट मी नो फर्स्ट गाइस। इफ दिस माजरा इज़
क्लियर टू यू।
एवरीवन आई वांट रिस्पांस फ्रॉम एवरीवन।
देखो बहुत लोग यहां से लीव कर चुके हैं
ट्रेनिंग। देखो मैं आपको क्लियर बताता
हूं।
जिनके बस की बात नहीं है वो ऑब्वियस सी
बात है लीव करेंगे। कुछ ऐसे भी लर्नर्स
होते हैं जिनको बस प्रैक्टिकल प्रैक्टिकल
करना है। सिर्फ प्रैक्टिकल कर लेंगे ना तो
खुश हो जाते हैं बेचारे वो। ऐसे लर्नर्स
के लिए कोई वैल्यू नहीं होती है मेरे पास।
एंड मैं केयर भी नहीं करता। आई डोंट केयर
एट ऑल।
बट जब प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट आएगा तो उनको वह
भी नहीं समझ में आएगा क्योंकि थ्यरी वाला
पार्ट समझ में नहीं आया। कांसेप्ट खत्म
कांसेप्ट क्लियर ही नहीं हो पाया। तो क्या
कर सकते हैं? तो ऐसे आई डोंट केयर अबाउट
दोज़ लर्नर्स। मुझे उनसे मतलब है जो अभी भी
यहां पे प्रेजेंट हैं एंड इंटरेस्ट शो कर
रहे हैं। दैट्स इट। ऑल क्लियर।
हां जी। जी हर हर जगह हर सभा में यही रूल
होता है। हर जगह यही रूल है।
अभी जो आप लोग हैं जो थ्यरी वाले पार्ट
में कंटिन्यू है आप जब प्रैक्टिकल आएगा ना
तो आपको ही उस टाइम सबसे ज्यादा समझ में
आएगा। बाकी लोगों को नहीं आने वाला है।
मैं मैं सच बता रहा हूं। बाकी लोग आएंगे
भी ना तो वो बस प्रैक्टिकल देखेंगे कि अरे
अच्छा कुछ हो रहा है इस आईएम डैशबोर्ड पे।
कुछ तो हो रहा है यहां पे। कुछ आ रहा है।
एक रिक्वेस्ट आई है या आईपी है। बट यह
आईपी एक्सटर्नल है। इंटरनल है। कुछ समझ
में नहीं आएगा। वह देख के बस प्रैक्टिकल
खुश होंगे। समझ में कुछ भी नहीं आएगा।
आपके लिए एक अपॉर्चुनिटी है। आई होप आप
इसको यूटिलाइज कर रहे हैं। अब खुद सोचिए
कि लगभग 49,000 डिफ्रॉनिक्सर्स
हमारे साथ जुड़े हैं YouTube इस चैनल पे।
49,000
मैं
अगर 49,000 का मैं एक बार निकाल के देखता
हूं।
49,000
का 1% निकालता हूं। 490 लोग होते हैं। का
1% 490 लोग। सोचो चार 1% भी नहीं है। चलो
मैं 49,000 का
1% निकालूं। 0.1% सोचो।
0.1%
तो होते हैं 49 49 लोग
भी सही से यहां पर नहीं है देखा जाए तो
राइट तो मैं मान नहीं सकता कि 49 को भी
इंटरेस्ट नहीं होगी एसओसी में या कुछ ऐसा
या सीखना नहीं चाहते होंगे ऐसा कुछ भी
नहीं है। बट द थिंग इज कि वैल्यू
अगर मैं इसी ट्रेनिंग को पेड करके लाता ना
तो बैच में ही 100 लोग हो जाते। सच बता
रहा हूं मैं। बैच में ही 100 लोग होते
हैं।
एंड उन्होंने इस ट्रेनिंग के लिए ₹10,000
भी दिए होते। ₹1,000 की फी भी पे करी होती
अरेंज करके या कैसे भी करके एंड हम भी खुश
हो जाते। हमारा भी अच्छा खासा रेवेन्यू हो
जाता बैच से। कंपनी के रेवेन्यू के लिए भी
अच्छा होता पूरे क्वार्टरली या ईयरली हम
मल्टीपल बैचेस लाते।
यहां फ्री में देने से हमें बहुत बहुत
बड़ा बेनिफिट तो नहीं हो रहा।
YouTube पर भी फॉलोवर्स जो बढ़ते हैं
सब्सक्राइबर्स आप देख ही रहे होंगे आप सभी
लोग इतने जल्दी तो नहीं बढ़ जा रहे हैं
एकदम से कि 5000 फॉलोवर एकदम से बढ़ गए
ऐसा तो है नहीं कुछ
तो उस चीज को समझ नहीं पाते काफी लोग जिस
दिन समझ जाएंगे या जो समझ जाएगा वो ऑलरेडी
बहुत अच्छा कर लेगा या कर चुका है या
करेगा आने वाले टाइम में एंड उसको कोई रोक
नहीं पाएगा दैट्स इट। आई होप कि ओवर द
टाइम यह ट्रेनिंग के वीडियोस जो है लोग
देखते रह, सीखते रह एंड आगे चलके अगर मैं
इसको मेंबर ओनली भी कर दूं, पेड भी कर दूं
तो भी लोग आएंगे। तो लेट्स सी अभी तो
फिलहाल फ्री है आप सबके लिए। इसको
यूटिलाइज कर लीजिए। ओके।
चलिए अब यह थ्री वे हैंडशक आपका आपको समझ
में आ गया होगा इस तरीके से काम करती है।
अब इसी थ्री वे हैंडशक में मैंने फ्लैग्स
की जिक्र की जैसे सिन के बारे में बताया
एसीके के बारे में बताया तो टीसीपी
फ्लैग्स कुछ होते हैं। मल्टीपल फ्लैग्स
होते हैं। मैंने तो अभी आपको जो इसमें
जिक्र किया है यहां पे सिन और एसीके ओनली
बताया सिंक्रोनाइज एंड एसीके। अब ऐसी जो
कम्युनिकेशन रिक्वेस्ट जो ऐसी जो
कम्युनिकेशन हो रही है क्लाइंट और सर्वर
के बीच में तो इसमें और भी फ्लैग्स होते
हैं। जैसे सन रिक्वेस्ट का मतलब
सिंक्रोनाइज ये स्टार्ट करता है कनेक्शन
अटेमप्ट करता है कि भैया कनेक्शन अब
स्टार्ट करते हैं। एसीके कंफर्मेशन के लिए
होता है। जैसे मैंने बताया किसी भी तरह का
कोई कंफर्मेशन हो तो वो एसीके के थ्रू
होता है। ये नॉर्म के मतलब कि नॉर्मल
ट्रैफिक। एक फिन रिक्वेस्ट भी होती है। एक
फिन फ्लैग भी होता है जिसका मतलब होता है
क्लोज।
यह ग्रेसफुली सेशन को एंड करना होता है।
मतलब फिन का मतलब होता है फिनिश।
ग्रेसफुली मतलब बहुत अच्छे से प्यार से इस
पर्टिकुलर दो एक सेशन को टर्मिनेट करना या
कम्युनिकेशन को टर्मिनेट करना होता है। बट
एक और फ्लैग होता है आर एसटी रिसेट। यह
होता है बहुत ही
डिफरेंट वे में टर्मिनेट करना। एबनॉर्मली
टर्मिनेट करना। अचानक से टर्मिनेट कर देना
कोई सेशन को। अचानक से बंद कर देना किसी
पर्टिकुलर कम्युनिकेशन को। तो उसके लिए आर
एसटी होता है, रेस्ट होता है
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] या रिसेट बोल
लीजिए। उसके बाद पीएसएच होता है। पुश डाटा
यह कोई डेटा को इमीडिएटली डिलीवर करना है
कम्युनिकेशन के अंदर में तो पीएसएच फ्लैग
को यूज़ किया जाता है कि इसको इमीडिएटली
डिलीवर करो। और यूआरजी होता है अर्जेंट।
अगर कोई अर्जेंट डाटा है, अर्जेंट कुछ ऐसा
कुछ कम्युनिकेशन है तो उसके लिए यूआरजी
यूज़ किया जाता है जो कि बहुत रेयर यूज़
होता है। ऐसे जनरली यूज़ में होता नहीं है।
ऐसा कुछ अर्जेंट कुछ होता नहीं है। तो ये
कुछ फ्लैग्स हैं जो आपको दिमाग में रखने
हैं। इनके बारे में आप इंटरनेट पे थोड़ी
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। एज अ टास्क भी आप
रख सकते हैं। की पॉइंट्स को Lindin पे
जरूर डालिए। Lindin पे डाल के पॉइंट्स की
पॉइंट्स को डालिए। वहां पे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स को
टैग कीजिए। लोगों को बताइए इन वीडियोस के
बारे में। मेड डिफ्रॉनिक्स जब आप की पॉइंट
डालते हैं तो अपने Lindin पोस्ट में आप
वीडियोस के लिंक भी डाल सकते हैं। रेफर कर
सकते हैं लोगों को कि यह वीडियोस है। यह
प्लेलिस्ट है जहां से आप देख रहे हैं। आप
सीख रहे हैं। तो लोगों तक पहुंचती है ये
सीरीज। मैक्सिमम लोगों तक पहुंचती है। मेन
मुद्दा वही है, मेन मोटिव वही है कि फ्री
में अगर कुछ हम डिलीवर कर रहे हैं,
क्वालिटी के साथ कर रहे हैं, तो उसको
मैक्सिमम लोगों तक हम पहुंचा सकें। यह एक
मेन मोटिव रहता है मेरा। आई होप कि
मैक्सिमम एसओसी एंथोजियास्ट जो है उन तक
यह पहुंचती होगी। आपके थ्रू ही पहुंच सकती
है मैक्सिमम लोगों तक। मैं अकेला कितना भी
कुछ कर लूं, मार्केटिंग कर लूं या कितना
भी कुछ शेयरिंग करवा लूं, कुछ भी कर लूं
या हमारे पास लाखों का डेटाबेस है वहां
तक। लेकिन एक्चुअल जो ये ट्रांसमिट होगा,
एक्चुअल जो यह फैलेगा, पहुंचेगा एक्चुअल
डिर्विंग लोगों तक या एंथूजियास्ट लोगों
तक वो आपके थ्रू होगा। तो आप अपना इसमें
एक रोल प्ले कर सकते हैं। तो बेसिकली तीन
जो स्टेप्स हैं वो यहां दिख रहा है।
क्लाइंट सीन रिक्वेस्ट, सीन फ्लैग, सर्वर
सीन एसीके फ्लैग, क्लाइंट एसी के फ्लैग
एंड कनेक्शन जो है इस्टैब्लिश्ड। कनेक्शन
इस्टैब्लिश हो जाती है। दैट्स इट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ये पूरा
माजरा है आपका। अब यहां पे कुछ सस्पिशियस
पैटर्न है। अगर आप एक एसओसी हैं तो यहां
पे एक सस्िशियस पैटर्न को आपको समझना
चाहिए। जब ऐसा पैटर्न दिखे तो समझिए कि
कुछ गड़बड़ है। अगर आपको सिर्फ सन ओनली
फ्लैग दिख रहे हैं किसी कम्युनिकेशन में।
समझिए कि सन फ्लड अटैक नाम का एक डॉस अटैक
होता है। सन फ्लड उस तरह का कोई अटैक होने
वाला है। जहां सिर्फ सन रिक्वेस्ट आपको
सीन फ्लैग्स मिल रहे हैं। ऑब्वियस सी बात
है। सन फ्लैग्स ओनली नहीं मिलने चाहिए।
बाकी के भी फ्लैग्स होने चाहिए। सन और फिन
मिल रहा है तो यहां पे समझ लीजिए कि यह
किसी तरह का एक मलिशियस स्कैन हो सकता है
जो किया जा रहा है अटैकर के द्वारा आपके
नेटवर्क की आरएसटी फ्लड अगर आपको मिल रहा
है मतलब कि यह आपके कम्युनिकेशन को
डिसरप्ट करने के लिए डिस्टर्ब करने के लिए
यूज़ में लिया जा रहा है। मतलब अचानक ही
किसी कम्युनिकेशन को टर्मिनेट करने का
कोशिश किया जा रहा है। तो यह आरएसटी फ्लड
अटैक के उसमें आ जाएगा। डिसररप्शन टाइप की
चीजें क्रिएट करने के लिए। एसीके नो एसीके
मतलब एसीके है ही नहीं इसका मतलब है हाफ
ओपन अटैक यानी कि सिर्फ सन रिक्वेस्ट जा
रही है और एसीके का कुछ रिस्पांस ही एसीके
कुछ आ ही नहीं रहा कुछ आ ही नहीं इसका
मतलब वो एक बैकलग क्रिएट होगा एक एक
कंजेशन क्रिएट होगा और उसकी वजह से क्या
होगा कि ये हाफ ओपन अटैक हो जाएगा मतलब
बेसिकली क्या होगा कि सन रिक्वेस्ट ओनली
जा रही है लेकिन एसी के आ ही नहीं रहा कुछ
हो ही नहीं रहा तो इसको हम हाफ ओपन अटैक
बोलते हैं। इसके बारे में थोड़ा एक्सप्लोर
कर लीजिएगा। तो इस तरीके की चीजें एज
एसओसी एल1 आपको थोड़ा दिमाग में आपके होना
चाहिए। दैट्स इट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब एसओसी
सिनेरियो की अगर हम बात करें रियल एसओसी
सिनेरियो की तो कुछ इस तरीके का अगर आपको
दिखता है कहीं पे सोर्स आईपी पैकेट्स आपको
दिख रहे हैं एसी के यहां डेस्टिनेशन। तो
अब देखो यहां पे पैकेट्स यहां पे कितने
दिख रहे हैं? 1 लाख सिं पैकेट्स दिख रहे
हैं। एसी के ज़ीरो है यहां पे। तो यहां पे
सिन फ्लड डीडीओस अटैक होने के चांसेस बढ़
जाते हैं। इनका कंक्लूजन आप ये निकाल सकते
हो कि सोर्स आईपी कोई सी भी हो यहां पे
मैक्सिमम ये देख रहे हो आप एक फॉरेन आईपी
है मतलब वैन आईपी है तो यहां पे अचानक से
अब सिर्फ इतने सीन पैकेट्स क्यों कोई
भेजेगा भाई ऐसी क्या रिक्वायरमेंट है तो
यहां पे कुछ सिन फ्लड अटैक होने वाला है
सिंस अटैक सीन अटैक को फ्लड किया जा रहा
है एंड ये एज एसओसी आपको समझना पड़ेगा तो
ये पूरी की पूरी सिनेरियो थी आज की जहां
पे आपने बेसिकली पैकेट्स के बारे में समझा
समझा आईपी पैकेट्स के बारे में आपने
टीटीएल के बारे में समझा, थ्री वे हैंडशक
के बारे में समझा। एंड आपको ये सारी चीजें
समझ में आ गई होंगी। तो आज का सेशन बस
इतना ही था। आई होप कि आपको मजा आया होगा।
आपको सीखने को तो जरूर मिला होगा कुछ ना
कुछ। एंड मैं चाहता हूं कि सेशंस जो भी हो
वो एज बेसिक एज आई कैन उसको डिलीवर कर
सकूं। जितना भी बिगिनर फ्रेंडली हो सके
मैं कर सकूं। मैं यह हमेशा आपके लिए कोशिश
करता हूं। यह बात याद रखिएगा। तो आपको बस
फॉलो करना होता है और जो पैटर्न है जो
चीजें हैं वो मैं सब पैटर्न वही है जो एक
जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग के लिए रिक्वायर्ड होती
है। वही चीजें चलती रहेंगी आपकी एंड आपको
फ्रीक्वेंट सेशंस में भी मिलते रहेंगे। आप
कमेंट्स जरूर करा कीजिएगा हर सेशन के एंड
होने के बाद कम से कम 150 कमेंट 150
कमेंट्स कर दिया कीजिए ताकि उससे
इनकरेजमेंट भी मिलती है। एक बंदा एक ही
कमेंट प्लीज करना। मल्टीपल मत करना
क्योंकि हाइड करने के बाद आपके सारे कमेंट
डिलीट हो जाते हैं। जैसे जैसे मुझे लास्ट
कुछ वीडियोस पे जब डाउट हुआ कि एक बंदा जो
है वो मल्टीपल कमेंट कर रहा है तो जब उसकी
यूजर को आईडी को हाइड करूंगा ना मैं अपने
अपने चैनल से तो वो उसके जितने कमेंट्स
हैं सब हट जाएंगे। हाइड हो जाएंगे। तो
नंबर ऑफ कमेंट्स रिड्यूस हो तो मुझे पता
चल गया कि कौन था। तो ऐसा मत करो रियल
करो। ऑथेंटिक रहो बी ऑथेंटिक जेन्युइन
रहो। दैट्स इट। तो यहां पे आई होप कि आपको
मजा आ गया होगा। एंड नेक्स्ट क्लास जो है
आपको फिर जल्दी आ जाएगी। एंड नेटवर्किंग
का पार्ट जल्दी आपका खत्म हो जाएगा। तो
आपका फिर दूसरे पार्ट पे आएंगे एंड फिर हम
रियल एसओसी जो हमारा टूल प्रैक्टिकल और ये
सब है होते हुए करते हुए हम इसको इस
ट्रेनिंग को खत्म करेंगे। तो इस ट्रेनिंग
के खत्म होने में बहुत ज्यादा टाइम अब
नहीं है। जब हम एक्चुअल
एसआईएम और ये सब जो प्रैक्टिकली करना सीख
जाएंगे। अलर्ट को समझना अलर्ट को बेसिकली
एस्केलेट कैसे करते हैं या कब करते हैं?
किस केस में करेंगे? कैटेगराइज़ करना, ट्रू
पॉजिटिव, फॉल्स पॉजिटिव इन सब चीजों में
तो उसके बाद आपका यह ट्रेनिंग कंप्लीट हो
जाएगा। एल1 के लिए उतनी ही रिक्वायरमेंट
आपकी होती है। तो एज एसोस एल1 आप प्रिपेयर
हो जाएंगे। बट अभी तो अब कुछ चीजें बची है
तो वो हम करेंगे पहले। देन हम एंड की तरफ
आएंगे तो आपको मजा आएगा फिर। हालांकि
फिलहाल के लिए मुझे ऐसा लगता है कि अभी
कितने? 16 क्लासेस हुए हैं। ऑलमोस्ट
30 क्लासेस तक हो जाने चाहिए कंप्लीट जहां
तक मुझे लग रहा है। बट लेट्स सी। हाउ मेनी
क्लासेस आर मोर लेफ्ट वी विल सी राइट
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़][गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
थैंक यू सो मच फॉर टुडे सेशन वी आर वेलकम
कश्मीर
कश्मीरा गवंदे ओके नईम अब्बास
प्लीज सर इस कोर्स को पढ़ना करूं क्या
पढ़ना क्या बोल रहे हो यार बंद थोड़ी ना
हो रही है कुलदीप कब तक हो जाएगी डिपेंड
करता है यह मैं फिक्स टाइम कुछ नहीं
बताऊंगा
फिक्स टाइम मैं कुछ नहीं बताऊंगा। फिक्स
टाइम इज नॉट देयर क्योंकि आप लोग में से
फिर बोलने लगते हैं कि सर इतने टाइम ले
रहे हो यह वो ऐसे वैसे बट तीन चार महीने
मैंने बोला था वही मान के चल लो तीन चार
या मैक्सिमम 5 महीने टोटल जिसमें से अभी
काफी टाइम तो हो चुका है थोड़े बचे हुए
एंड आपके वो कंप्लीट हो जाएंगे। फिर यू
विल बी एकदम जॉब रेडी। आप जॉब रेडी रहोगे
एसओसी एल वन के लिए। इट्स माय गारंटी। बस
इतना ही मुझे पता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है। सो थैंक यू वेरी मच गाइस। यहां
टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
सभी लोगों को। फॉर स्कल ओके आशीष कुमार
ओके तो यह टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट है। ऑब्वियस
सी बात है मैं सबके नाम नहीं ले पाऊंगा।
50 लोग लगभग होते हैं तो कांट टेक ऑल द
नेम्स बट दीज़ आर द लिस्ट एंड दीज़ पीपल आर
वेरी एक्टिव एंड हियर। सो थैंक यू वेरी मच
टू दीज़ पीपल एंड रिमेनिंग ऑल द पीपल हु आर
अटेंडिंग द सेशंस। क्योंकि मुझे लगता है
कि आप सेशन अटेंड कर थैंक यू। मैं क्यों
बोलता हूं? मैं थैंक यू इसलिए नहीं बोलता
हूं क्योंकि आप सेशन देखने आते हो। यह तो
आपको आपको देखना है। आपकी आपके काम की चीज
है। वह आपके लिए है। तो आपको तो आना ही
है। मैं थैंक यू इसलिए बोलता हूं आपको
क्योंकि आप ज्यादा नंबर में जब आते हो या
रहते हो तो मुझे अच्छा लगता है।
इनकरेजमेंट मिलती है। बट अगर नहीं रहोगे
तो वो शायद नहीं मिले। फिर वो आपके साथ
वही है डिलेव होती है। ये चीज होती है। तो
ये सारे लोग हैं टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट में।
यू कैन सी ऑल दीज़ पीपल। ओके
दैट्स इट। ओके। चलिए बहुत बढ़िया। नाउ वी
विल एंड द सेशन एंड वी विल बी कंटिन्यूइंग
इन द नेक्स्ट सेशन विद द न्यू टॉपिक एंड
देन जल्दी हम एंड की तरफ बढ़ेंगे। थैंक यू
वेरी मच गाइस एंड वीडियो को शेयर जरूर
कीजिएगा अपने दोस्तों के बीच अपने उस
नेटवर्क एसओसी एंथोजियास्ट जो ऑडियंस है
उनके बीच लोगों के बीच जिनको एसओसी के
बारे में सीखना है एक्चुअल लर्निंग लेनी
है एक्चुअल स्किल्स गेन करना है बिल्कुल
फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट क्वालिटी के साथ जॉब रेडी
एक ट्रेनिंग लेनी है तो उनको वीडियो जरूर
शेयर कीजिएगा एंड सब्सक्राइब नहीं करा तो
सब्सक्राइब करके बेल आइकॉन प्रेस कर
दीजिएगा थैंक यू वेरी मच गाइस एंड हैव अ
गुड डे गुड नाइट एक्चुअली एंड नमस्ते टू
एवरीबॉडी टाटा